Du denkst wahrscheinlich, dass...
So, ich glaube jetzt ist...
Ja, ja, ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Hast du auf dem Host
WSL 2 installiert?
Und wenn ja, wie hast du das konfiguriert,
dass in deinem VMware nested
Virtualization klappt? Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich glaube,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, ich hatte
die gleichen Probleme wie du.
Wenn man... Also nicht nur
WSL 2, generell
wenn man die Windows
11 Virtualisierungs
Zeug
aktiviert...
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm geht einfach nicht mehr.
Was ist jetzt? Wenn man die Windows 11
Virtualisierungskacke
aktiviert, dann hat
VMware Probleme.
In VMware musste man dann irgendeine
Option setzen, glaube ich, dass es wieder
funktioniert. Aber das kann durchaus
sein, dass nested Virtualisierung bei mir
dann auch nicht geklappt hat.
Ich habe dieses ganze Windows 11
Virtualisierungs Zeug habe ich aus.
Grüß Gott für den Sub.
Das habe ich alles aus.
Ich meine, ich brauche auch kein
WSL. Ich habe halt ein richtig
echtes Linux, was mir viel, viel
lieber ist als ein WSL.
Ich muss jetzt mal gerade checken.
Ich habe euch nämlich was aufgenommen
unterwegs. Weiß nicht, ob das
was geworden ist.
Da muss ich euch einmal kurz
ausblenden.
RIP Docker Desktop. Warum?
Ach so, Docker Desktop unter Windows,
oder wie?
Oder was willst du machen?
Docker Desktop.
Docker Desktop unter Windows?
Das ist aber echt Hardcore Pains
Champ schon, ne?
Ich weiß, dass ihr gerade nichts
seht übrigens.
Ich will mal ein Video
von meinem iPhone rüberziehen. Ich habe keine
Ahnung, was ich da alles
leake.
Was ich nicht leaken möchte.
Deswegen habe ich euch gleich mal
ausgeblendet.
Und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher,
ob das Aufnehmen
überhaupt
funktioniert hat.
Schauen wir mal.
Ob das das richtige Video ist.
VLC starten.
Ja, ja, das ist das richtige Video.
Alles klar.
Moment, ich mache euch wieder an.
Und ich mache das iPhone erstmal ab.
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
So.
Jetzt mache ich euch wieder an.
Moment.
Da.
So.
Das Problem mit WSL 2 ist immer,
mir fallen immer keine großen Gründe
immer so
retrospektivisch ein.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich
längere Zeit WSL 2 probiere,
geht es mir auf den Sack und ich bin froh, dass ich ein
vollwertiges Linux habe.
Ich hatte sogar irgendwo mal eine Liste angefangen,
warum was an
WSL 2 nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und
ich weiß aber nicht mehr,
wo ich das habe.
Also ich war oft,
als ich das ausprobiert habe, froh oder schnell.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung mehr, was so die großen
Probleme mit WSL 2 waren.
Habe ich, wo habe ich denn?
Ich habe irgendwo eine Liste erstellt.
Aber ich glaube nicht hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wo ich das habe.
Chat, fällt euch irgendwas ein,
was mit WSL 2
nicht gescheit funktioniert?
Ich finde das nicht mehr. Ich gucke gerade auf
meinem zweiten, in meinem Notes,
in meinen Notes,
auf dem zweiten
Rechner, aber ich finde, ich habe mir extra
eine Liste gemacht, was mir an WSL
nicht gefallen hat.
Vielleicht müssen wir es im Stream ausprobieren,
dass wir live drauf kommen, was kacke ist.
Aber es gibt einige Sachen, die mir unglaublich
auf den Sack gegangen sind. Deswegen habe ich das nie weiter
verwendet. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
du kannst ja in WSL beispielsweise auch
nicht gescheit i3 laufen lassen und so was.
Du kannst ja kein gescheites
Desktop Environment, also sagen wir mal so,
du kannst das bestimmt mit sehr
viel Getrickse laufen lassen, aber
das funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Dann mit dem,
selbst mit dem Microsoft X Server,
oder das ist ja gar kein X Server,
ich glaube, das WSL,
wie heißt das, WSLG oder so,
ist das nicht sogar irgendein Wayland-Gedöns?
Ja, aber
allein schon, weil ich i3 verwenden will unter Linux,
ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, so Sachen
wie SSHFS gingen auch nicht
richtig.
Wobei, nee,
das war ein WSL1-Problem, glaube ich.
Ja,
keine Ahnung. Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Aber
Trust me, Bro.
Wie man da so schön sagt heutzutage.
Das hat schon seinen Grund, warum ich WSL nicht verwende.
Ist mir oft zu sehr auf den Sack gegangen.
Ohne, dass ich dir jetzt sagen kann,
was das genau die Probleme
waren im Einzelnen.
Ja gut, aber
das ist doch trotzdem VMs.
Wenn du WSL hast, WSL ist doch auch
eine VM. Also du kommst
für Docker an einer VM eh nicht vorbei.
Okay, Windows-Container vielleicht.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt absolut keine Ahnung habe, wie Windows-Container
funktionieren. Wahrscheinlich ist es unter der Haube
dann Windows-VM für jeden Container oder so.
Was ist deine Meinung
zum Bahnstreik? Findest du die Forderung
der GDL berechtigt?
Ich, okay.
Ja, also keine, also
ob die berechtigt ist oder nicht
im Bahn-Kontext, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich finde die Forderung,
das ist tatsächlich eine sehr vielschichtige
Frage, ja. Also ich finde
die Forderung der GDL gut.
Weil,
nicht weil ich irgendwie komplett selbstlos bin
und will, dass die unbedingt hier das
alles bekommen. Ehrlich gesagt ist mir das scheißegal.
Hauptsache die Bahn funktioniert.
Das, was mir
persönlich gefällt ist an der Forderung
von der GDL, dass
die 35-Stunden-Woche fordern.
Und ich bin da recht
egoistisch und ich finde es
an jeder Ecke gut, wo
weniger als klassische
40-Stunden-38-Stunden-Woche gefordert wird.
Weil, umso normaler
das wird,
umso größer sind
die Chancen, dass das mal
ja, ob das jemals
gesetzlich kommt, wage ich zu bezweifeln,
aber umso größer sind die Chancen, dass das
immer normaler wird. Und wisst ihr,
was das heißt, wenn das immer normaler wird,
4-Tage-Woche zu arbeiten?
Ratet mal, was könnte das
heißen für jemand, der
schon 4 Tage arbeitet in der Woche?
Was könnte das bedeuten?
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder 3-Tage-Woche,
Incoming oder
volles Gehalt bei weiter 4 Tage.
Also, insofern...
Also, insofern, ich bin da gar nicht so selbstlos,
da ich selbst seit
über... ach, seit 10 Jahren
glaube ich sogar schon, 4-Tage-Woche
arbeite, bin ich
sofort dafür, alle
4-Tage-Woche zu geben, was nämlich dann bedeuten würde,
ich kriege 100% Geld.
Also, das finde ich,
den Part der Forderung finde ich tatsächlich
gut. Umso normaler wird das,
umso besser. Ich habe letztens auch irgendeinen Artikel gelesen,
das glaube ich die Commerzbank oder irgendjemand
das auch machen möchte.
Da ist es dann irgendwie so,
dass man
4-Tage-Woche bekommt,
bei vollem Gehalt, allerdings
nicht komplett einen Tag
die Arbeitszeit reduziert wird, wenn ich das
richtig im Hinterkopf habe. Also, da wird
dann quasi reduziert von, sagen wir mal,
40 Stunden auf
36 Stunden oder so.
Und du darfst sie dann aber
halt an 4 Tagen anstatt an 5
arbeiten. Das heißt, du musst jeden Tag eine Stunde länger da bleiben
und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, die denken sich alle Modelle
aus gerade. Und umso normaler
das wird, umso besser ist das.
Ja, also ich finde das
gut. So, und die andere
Frage ist, ob ich
Alter, ich bin ja
gerade gerannt wieder meine
10,5 Kilometer. Mir läuft immer noch
die Nase. Sekunde, warte mal.
So, also,
das ist ja eine sehr
vielschichtige Frage. Deswegen würde ich
gerne sagen,
die,
also, gucken wir mal auf
Twitter. Da gibt es ja die Leute, die
immer bei sowas dann ganz
so,
so moralisch schreiben.
Mein vollsten Support
an die GDL.
Jeder, der das nicht für gut heißt, ist
ein Kack-Spaß, so nach dem Motto. Und
ja, immer, weil alles
gute Bahnleute und so. Also,
ich finde, das ist eine,
das kann ich nicht teilen.
Und da sieht man mal, wie widersprüchlich
man eigentlich Sachen finden
kann. Also, prinzipiell
muss ich sagen, wenn
mich jemand fragen würde, sollte
man verbieten, dass die Bahn, oder generell
sollte man das den Leuten verbieten, dass sie
streiten, dann würde ich sagen, nein, sollte man nicht.
Das ist denen ihr Recht, das dürfen
sie. Da wäre ich auch,
da würde ich tatsächlich auch, wenn man da aus irgendwelchen
Gründen angenommen würde, dürfte abstimmen. So, dürfte man das
verbieten. Würde ich dagegen stimmen?
Das würde ich bei allen dagegen stimmen.
Dass das verboten werden sollte.
Trotzdem, umgedrehter Fall,
ist mir das eigentlich scheißegal
und ich bin abgefuckt, dass das scheiß nicht
funktioniert. Also, ich habe
keine Solidarität, wie soll man das sagen,
mit den Streikenden.
Ich bin aber für das Recht, dass sie streiken dürfen.
Versteht mal, was ich meine.
Das ist irgendwie sehr widersprüchlich, aber so ist es.
Ich meine, nur weil ich das prinzipiell richtig
finde, dass sie streiken dürfen und streiken,
heißt es nicht, dass ich es geil finden
muss.
Dass sie streiken.
Und
mir ist es auch
egal, wer da jetzt was für kann oder
nicht.
Letztendlich ist es verkackt,
wie viel ist bei der Bahn.
Historische Entscheidungen,
Managemententscheidungen,
auf Regierungsebene Entscheidungen
und generell ist die Bahn einfach mal komplett am Arsch.
Der Wieselski hat ja
letztens auch irgendwie so den
Mikrofon-Drop
hingelegt,
in dem er irgendwie gesagt hat,
in irgendeinem Interview,
dass sich jetzt ausgerechnet die
CSU beschwert, das war irgendwas in Bayern, glaube ich,
dass sich jetzt ausgerechnet die CSU
beschwert, ist ja schon ein kompletter Witz.
Die sind ja dafür verantwortlich, dass die
Bahn so ein Scheißladen ist. Das hat er nicht
wortwörtlich gesagt, aber sinngemäß.
Der hatte schon ein paar Dinge
rausgehauen.
Die Bahn ist gefühlt immer streik,
ja, also in letzter Zeit sehr oft.
Es gab letztens eine Statistik, habe ich gesehen,
Pünktlichkeiten
der
öffentlichen,
tja, Bahninfrastruktur
in den jeweiligen Ländern.
Die Schweiz war ganz weit
oben, Italien kam noch vor
uns und wir waren auf dem vorletzten
Platz, nach uns kam nur noch
Slowenien.
Und ich glaube, wir hatten 65%
oder so, oder
70%
oder irgendwie sowas, der
Züge. Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge,
zeigen lassen. Die sind so unglaublich
bodenlos scheiße, dieser Drecksladen.
Alter, diese Kackfinger. Ich könnte
mich den ganzen Tag nur über die...
Wisst ihr ja, muss ich jetzt nicht...
Muss ich jetzt nicht anfangen.
Wenn ich danach mich nicht anfange.
Ja, aber wisst ihr,
jetzt mal,
jetzt mal, jetzt mal
Spaß beiseite.
Überlegt euch mal,
vor drei Wochen oder so
und das
und das, das ist richtig.
Take Viagra, da hat das richtig.
Die Bahnen dürfen
ihre eigene Statistik
erstellen, die dürfen die Regeln
für die eigenen Statistiken festlegen,
die dürfen die Ziele, die erreicht
werden, quasi mehr oder weniger
selbst festlegen und
trotzdem werden die verfehlt.
Das musst du erstmal schaffen. Also, da könnt
ihr Gift drauf nehmen. Wenn ich meine eigene
Statistik erstellen dürfte und mir
die eigenen Regeln dafür ausdecken dürfte
und dann auch noch
überlegen dürfte, quasi, wann war es
gilt und was nicht, dann würde ich aber
wenigstens im Ziel bleiben. Aber nein und nicht
mal das kriegen wir auf die Reihe. Könnt ihr
sicher sein. Ja, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber, jetzt Spaß beiseite.
Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist,
müsst ihr euch überlegen, vor drei Wochen
war der erste Bahnstreik dieses
Jahr. Anfang Januar.
Dann
war Unwetter
und
Bauern
in Frankfurt. Dann war
Glatteis und
Schnee und Dingsbums-Chaos
und jetzt ist wieder Bahnstreik.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen. Du konntest
quasi drei Wochen
lang jetzt. Wir sind nicht in
irgendeinem Loch in Afrika oder so, ja.
Wir sind in Hessen, in Deutschland, in
Frankfurt. Nicht irgendwo
in der dritten Welt.
Du konntest quasi drei Wochen
nicht mit
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln gescheit fahren.
Drei Wochen.
Wie gesagt, wir sind nicht in einem dritten.
Weltland, irgendwo im Busch, in irgendeinem
Loch in Afrika. Nein.
Und da funktioniert das besser.
Da wärst du in drei Wochen angekommen.
Okay, ich mein, du wärst vielleicht unterwegs
erschossen, erstochen, sonst. Wobei,
du musst durch Offenbach durchfahren.
Ich nehm das zurück.
Vielleicht ist das auch kein Unterschied, ja.
Gut, ich glaub, es ist zumindest hier immer noch
ein bisschen sicherer, die Strecke zu fahren, ja.
Aber das ist wirklich,
das ist wirklich echt affig, wenn man
sich das überlegt. Drei Wochen
lang, dass du es komplett vergessen
konntest. Ja, ja, ich nehm
das zurück, wie gesagt.
Muss man sagen, so ungefährlich ist es ja
hier auch nicht. Es gab ja die letzte Zeit wieder
einige Meldungen
über Leute mit
Messer am Bahnhof, Messer
im Zug mit der Axt.
Gab's auch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mit der
Axt, wo jemand durch den Zug gelaufen
ist und versucht hat, Leute
anzuaksten.
Der wurde dann erschossen, hat es die Leute wieder aufgeregt,
warum wurde der denn erschossen? Ah ja, der ist
mit der Axt durch den Zug gerannt und wollte auf Leute
einschlagen.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich
weiß ja nicht, wie ihr das seht. Da gibt's immer
so große Diskussionen. Also,
ich bin wirklich nicht dafür,
dass das so läuft, wie
Kekona Land.
Hell yeah, dass alles abgeknallt wird,
was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen
ist, ja. Das muss ja nicht sein.
Oder, wenn du die falsche
Hautfarbe hast, dass dir die Polizei auf dir
rumspringt oder was. Da bin ich ja
wirklich nicht dafür. Aber
wir machen teilweise das,
die Amis haben andere Probleme, aber wir haben teilweise
echt, ist das hier echt
übertrieben, bei
jeder,
wie soll man sagen,
fast schon Pflichterfüllung
der Polizei, wird
ultra rumgejammert. Ich hab letztens ein Video
gesehen, das war so ein typisches Video
von der Kategorie, was ich mir nicht hätte
angucken sollen, weil eigentlich will man sich sowas nicht
angucken. Aber war auf Twitter,
stehen drei
oder vier Polizisten auf der Straße und
vor ihnen steht ein halb nackiger Typ mit einem Messer in der Hand.
Und die
schreien ihn halt an, er soll nicht näher
kommen, er soll das Messer weglegen,
sie gehen sogar noch einen Schritt zurück,
er soll das Messer weglegen und
dann läuft er halt auf die zu mit dem Messer nach vorne.
Und dann erschießen sie ihn.
Da denk ich mir so, what the fuck?
Alter, was?
Warum regt man sich
da drüber auf?
Ich mein, wer auf
der Straße steht mit dem Messer,
die Leute bedroht, mit dem
gezückten Messer Richtung Polizei
läuft auch noch.
Da musst du doch mit rechnen, dass du
die Sache nicht überlebst. Ich hab
keine Ahnung, versteh das auch nicht.
Wie sie sich drüber aufgeregt haben, dass sie den Kerl, der im
Zug rumgelaufen ist, mit der Axt erschossen
haben. Ja man, wenn einer in den
Zug einsteigt, mit dem Hintergedanken
jetzt mit der Axt auf ein paar Leute einzuschlagen,
dann muss der halt damit rechnen, dass er den Scheiß
nicht überlebt. Es ist ja nicht, als hätte ihn jemand dazu
gezwungen, mit der Axt in den Zug
einzusteigen und auf Leute einzuschlagen.
Da musst du damit rechnen.
Das verstehe ich teilweise echt nicht.
Ich persönlich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich hab auch nicht nur gute Erfahrungen
mit der Polizei gemacht, aber
insgesamt
finde ich eigentlich die Arbeit der Polizei ziemlich
gut. Ja und wir können froh sein,
dass wir gut ausgebildete Polizisten haben
und nicht Kona-Style.
Wenn du dir das da teilweise anguckst, ist das echt nicht
mehr normal.
Was ist an Offenbach
so besonders?
Haftbefehl?
Eigentlich ist an Offenbach gar nichts mehr so großartig
besonders. Offenbach ist halt gerade, was Hauptbahnhof
und Umgebung angeht, ziemlich runtergekommen.
Gut, Frankfurt auch.
Ist in Frankfurt jetzt nicht viel anders.
Historisch war Offenbach halt immer so ein bisschen
Brennpunkt, weil das einen extrem hohen Ausländeranteil
hat.
Und da ging es gerade im Bahnhofsviertel früher immer
zur Sache und auch was Kriminalitätsraten anbietet.
Und sowas war Offenbach halt früher berühmt, berüchtigt.
Aber mittlerweile würde ich sagen, ist Offenbach auch nicht mehr so wild,
zumal Offenbach ja auch nicht nur Hauptbahnhof ist.
Genauso wenig wie Frankfurt ist.
Frankfurt ist ja auch nicht nur Bahnhofsviertel.
Wenn man Reddit guckt, Reddit, Reddit Frankfurt, Reddit Frankfurt,
da wird, da wird gefühlt jeden Tag fünfmal gefragt,
ist es sicher, am Hauptbahnhof rumzulaufen und so?
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Das ist mittlerweile schon so ein Reddit Frankfurt Meme.
Ist es sicher am Hauptbahnhof?
Ja, es ist sicher am Hauptbahnhof.
Wir sind hier nicht irgendwie in den Slums in Brasilien oder so.
Du kannst am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt ohne Probleme rein und raus
laufen, ohne dass du erschossen, erstochen, abgefackelt wirst.
Also dich kotzt vielleicht irgendein Penner an.
Oder so, das kann schon mal passieren.
Oder vor dich, oder ja, oder es fällt einer hin vor dir.
Oder es schreit dich einer von das.
Also es ist schon, schon weird Champ am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Aber es ist nicht, soll man sagen, nicht akut gefährlich da für Leib und Leben.
Aber man sieht halt Sachen, die man nicht sehen will.
Ja, du siehst zum Beispiel, dass da gibt's, weißt du schon,
letztens irgendwann, aber letztens ist gut, das ist bestimmt auch schon ein Jahr her,
ein Bild gepostet.
Auf Twitter Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, da lag einer in irgendeinem Schaufenster,
also es war kein Schaufenster mehr drin, lag irgendein Typ im Schaufenster und hat gepennt.
Halb, halb drinnen, halb draußen im Schaufenster mit nackigem Hintern halt aus dem Schaufenster
raus.
Lag da und schlief.
Es ist halt, das ist halt Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Du hast dann auch Leute neben dir, die auf einmal mit nackigen Füßen in der Bahn hocken
und sowas.
Also.
Die Quote Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof ist schon recht hoch, aber es ist nicht gefährlich
in diesem Sinn.
Du wurdest gebannt auf dem Discord, das weiß ich nicht, warum du auf dem Discord gebannt
wurdest.
Kann vielleicht einer der Modgis was zu sagen.
Aber ich habe es bis jetzt noch nie erlebt, dass jemand komplett grundlos gebannt wurde.
Das heißt, entweder hast du Eigenwerbung in übertriebenem Maß betrieben, fragwürdige
Sachen gepostet auf wiederholte Aufforderung von Modgis.
Weiterhin komische Sachen gepostet, illegale Sachen gepostet oder was auch immer getrieben.
Und für den Fall der Fälle, dass sich wirklich jemand geirrt hat, kann sich das ja einer
der Modgis nochmal angucken.
Aber die wissen das, falls überhaupt jemand da ist.
Ich habe nur Fragen zum IT-Job geschrieben.
Das klingt jetzt eigentlich nicht bannwürdig.
Mod, Modcheck?
Ich glaube, der Rinax ist da, also keine Ahnung.
Ja, ja, ein bisschen schon.
Was?
All das Profil, was lustige Pronomen enthielt.
Oh je, sind bestimmt irgendwelche Leute triggert.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es da genau ging.
Ich denke, wir müssen bei sowas auch nicht pipsiger sein als der Papst.
Aber wenn ihr es für richtig haltet, ich habe da Vertrauen in meine Modgis.
Sonst könnten wir den Discord gar nicht betreiben.
Ja, war ich.
Ach so, ich wollte euch eigentlich ein Video zeigen, ich wollte euch eigentlich ein Video
zeigen.
Und zwar.
Ich habe es gemerkt.
Das ist echt angenehm.
Das ist echt anstrengend, das zu rennen.
Deswegen habe ich versucht, mal aus Motivationsgründen ein Video aufzunehmen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob man mich überhaupt versteht da drinne.
Ja, ich habe mir gedacht, ich nehme einfach mal kurz eine Minute auf bei meiner Runde.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Na ja, gut, funktioniert.
Das ist so, dass die Aufnahme funktioniert, habe ich mir gedacht.
Ich weiß dann nicht, ob man mich versteht.
Natürlich wie der letzte Kacknub hochkant gefilmt.
So richtig.
Die TikTok-Generation, zu der ich ja natürlich nicht gehöre.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Ich habe übrigens 184 Zuschauer.
Passt irgendwie.
Mal gucken, ob man mich versteht.
Aber man sieht schönes Wetter.
Schönes Wetter.
So, hallo Leute.
Hier ist der Max.
Ja, man versteht was, oder?
Ja, man versteht was.
Keine Ahnung, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Man hört, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen aus der Puste bin.
So minimal, ja.
So, hallo Leute.
Hier ist der Max.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Aber echt schönes Wetter, oder?
Ja.
So, hallo Leute.
Hier ist der Max.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Aber echt schönes Wetter, oder?
Aber ich dachte mir aus Motivationsgründen, nehme ich mal kurz ein bisschen von meiner
Sonntagsrunde auf.
Aktuell ist gerade, guck mal, hörst du, ob man das sieht?
What the f...
Max, erkennt man da irgendwas?
Erkennt man auf...
Erkennt man...
Sekunde.
Erkennt man hier irgendwas?
Aktuell ist gerade, guck mal, hörst du, ob man das sieht?
Oh, ich habe mich bestimmt gespiegelt in der Uhr.
Von KS.
Ja, doch, man erkennt was, tatsächlich, tatsächlich.
Spiegelung in der Uhr bestimmt gewesen, also da erkennt man es.
Halbes Face-Reveal, ja, halbes Face-Reveal.
Mit dem T-Shirt, ne, ich habe kein T-Shirt angehabt.
Liegt, liegt, Teile der Hand und Arm liegt.
Also, was sieht man denn da drauf?
Haare am Arm liegt.
Ja.
Also, was, was sieht man da drauf?
Also, das da oben ist die errechnete Watt-Angabe, die ist sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen, ja,
sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
So, aktuell haben wir 3,1, also an der Stelle hatte ich 3,13 Kilometer, ich bin 20 Minuten
ungefähr gelaufen, 6 Minuten 25 pro Kilometer aktueller Pace, was ist das?
Ach so, Time of Day oder sowas.
9 Uhr 11 und 161er Puls, wo die Uhr der Meinung ist, dass es obere, äh, vorletzte, obere Hälfte
der vorletzten, ja, Anstrengungszone von mir, sagt meine Uhr, ja, wenn die das sagt, dann,
dann wird es so sein.
Was ist das für eine Uhr?
Das ist eine Garmin Forerunner 255.
Ja.
Ich meine, die ist nicht in Pink, ich habe so eine ganz normale graue, graue Armband,
aber die ist ganz nice, die ist nicht so teuer wie manche andere Uhren und, also, was ich
an der Uhr mag, jetzt gucken wir mal gerade, was das Ding bei Amazon kostet, die sind da
oftmals schlecht lieferbar, oh nein, schon wieder Postleitzahl liegt, ja, 264 Euro, ich
finde, das geht eigentlich voll klar, was ich, was ich an der, was ich an der Uhr ziemlich
gut finde, ist die Akkulaufzeit.
Weil, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit einer, sagen wir, Apple, Apple Watch, dann hält die
halt zehnmal so lang, die kannst du eine Woche rumliegen lassen oder beziehungsweise benutzen
und eine Woche nicht aufladen.
So eine Apple Watch ist nach einem Tag oder je nachdem, wie oft, wie viel man davon benutzt,
auch schneller leer.
Natürlich hat die bei weitem kein so großes und so hochauflösendes und so detailreiches
Display.
Sie hat ein, so ein Pulsmesser hast du da drinne.
Hm.
Und insgesamt ist es vielleicht jetzt nicht die absolute Highend-Uhr, aber die Akkulaufzeit
ist nice, Preis-Leistung finde ich nice und was ich bei Garmin persönlich gut finde, ist
das große Ökosystem aus Plugins und Datenfeldern und sowas.
Wir haben ja schon mal im Stream ein eigenes Datenfeld für meinen Fahrradcomputer programmiert
und dass man sie ultra nice customizen kann, ja, man hat auch die wichtigsten Sportarten
schon mit drinne.
Man kann auch diesen automatischen Trainingsplan-Generator benutzen, wenn man das mag, das verwende ich
aber nicht.
Ansonsten ist die echt nice, kann ich, kann ich gar nicht, fühlt sich gut an, man drückt
auch nicht aus versehen die Knöpfe, die Bedienung ist, nachdem man sich dran gewöhnt hat, sehr
eingängig.
Also ich, ich find die Uhr gut, ich würd die mir auch wiederholen, ja.
Was auch, was ich persönlich auch sehr sehr praktisch finde, ist, dass wenn man Streckenläuft,
die man nicht kennt.
Ja.
Dann kann man beispielsweise über Komoot oder irgendwo irgendwas, wo du GPS-Daten, also
nicht, also nicht GPS, wie heißt der, GPX, GPX, also wo du so Tracking, wo du so Wege
quasi exportieren kannst, kannst du dir kopieren auf die Uhr oder importieren, die meisten
Wande-Apps haben ja auch schon ne Connect-Funktion zu Garmin und dann kannst du quasi die Navigation
auf der Uhr machen.
Das ist die, die hat keine Kartenfunktion, also dafür ist das Display nicht gut genug,
du kannst keine Karten rendern im Hintergrund.
Aber du kannst dir so ne rote Linie anzeigen lassen und das reicht ja auch, weil du siehst
den Pfeil, in welche Richtung du guckst und du siehst die rote Linie und die Auflösung
von der roten Linie, ob du dich auf deinem richtigen Pfad befindest.
Also wenn ich irgendwo wandern gehe und den Weg nicht kenne, dann navigier ich mittlerweile
eigentlich zu 90% mit der Uhr und hol das Handy bloß an Stellen raus, wo es nicht ganz
eindeutig ist.
Und das ist viel nicer, als wenn man beispielsweise irgendwie durch, bisschen durch die Uhr geht,
aber du kannst dir so ne rote Linie anzeigen lassen und das reicht ja auch, weil du siehst
den Pfeil, in welche Richtung du guckst und du siehst die rote Linie und die Auflösung
von der Uhr eines Pfeils, wo es nicht ganz eindeutig ist.
Also wenn ich irgendwo wandern gehe und den Weg nicht ganz eindeutig ist, aber du kannst
dir das Handy bloß anstellen und das ist viel nicer, als wenn man beispielsweise irgendwie
durch, bisschen durchs Gelände läuft.
Und dann irgendwie noch, zusätzlich zu vielleicht links und rechts am Stock, noch irgendwie
das Handy rausholen muss, um da drauf zu gucken.
Und dann auch auf's Maul fällt, weil man nicht richtig gucken kann, aufs Handy.
Also das, die Navigationsfunktion sieht zwar super primitiv aus, ist aber enorm praktisch.
Ja?
Und nachdem man auch alle Datenfelder und so customizern kann, ist das, ist das sehr
nice.
Genau.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, mein, mein Video.
für euch und morgen aufgenommen weil so aus motivationsgründen ich habe ein bisschen ich
habe ein bisschen nachgelassen und weihnachten wir gucken uns aber das video erst mal fertig
an also ja wir sind von einer sonntagsrunde auf aktuell ist gerade mal naja man hat es
gesehen 625 pro kilometer 162 kurz beim regen geht das jetzt auch ein bisschen hoch und ich
dachte mir so aus motivationsgründen als aber echt schönes wetter ja
neue bestzeiten und so gibt es nicht
ja das stimmt bin ich nicht so viel gerannt über weihnachten es ging aber auch teilweise
nicht mehr mega scheiß wetter glatteis und alles jetzt die letzten tage
irgendwann im nächsten
probiere ich mal elf kilometer oder zehn kilometer irgendwas dazwischen und dann
unter sechs minuten pro kilometer die runde heute ist auch ungefähr elf kilometer also
ich hab jetzt habe ich jetzt 3,26 also ein drittel oder so ungefähr wenn man da großzügig ist
machts gut ich komm weiter bis dann c u
hauptsache c u am ende
ich habe mir gedacht ich nehme das mal auf vielleicht vielleicht motiviert mich
ja selbst ja heute waren es knapp zehn kilometer also es war nicht die nicht
die nicht die noch größere runde sondern nur die nur die zehn kilometer runde ich
habe ja das sage ich ganz nice ich habe ja die möglichkeit bei mir quasi mit dem
gleichen anfang der runde kann ich entweder fünf kilometer laufen
6,2 kilometer laufen 8 10 oder 11 halb laufen das ist alles immer quasi so die
gleiche runde aber unterschiedliche unterschiedliche abzweigungen das heißt
je nachdem wie es mir gerade ist kann ich das variieren und heute war es mir so
nach der zweitgrößten runde aber nicht die ganz große hat keinen bock drauf ja war ich schon aber
insgesamt um das jetzt abzuschließen
war es heute echt nicht gut ich hatte heute erstmal auf okay wie garmin das hat
keinen bock hoch kann zu gehen ich hatte ich bin heute gelaufen ziemlich genau
also knapp zehn kilometer durchschnittliche herzfrequenz 162 gut
hat man da auch gesehen so viel hatte ich da ja auch ungefähr sechs minuten 33
sogar nur pro kilometer
881 kalorien gebörnt
eine stunde fünf und von den stats her und von den städtchen es ist eigentlich
relativ relativ langweilig was ich was ich doof finde ist also der sagt trainings
trainingseffekt sind 5 5,0 mehr geht nicht mehr trainingseffekt kann man nicht
kann man nicht machen laut garmin ist das also ich habe quasi den maximalen
trainingseffekt fragt mich was garmin anzeigen würde wenn ich zwölf kilometer
gerannt wäre
weil ich glaube ich hätte mich noch mehr gefühlt dann wäre es noch besser und ich würde ich noch mehr lernen
weil ich habe eigentlich auch kein problem mit 10 kilometer gefahren wenn ich 12 kilometer gerannt wäre weil ich habe
mehr als mehr als 5,0 geht nicht und allerdings ist meine performance condition schlecht meine
performance condition also wo garmin garmin das errechnet weil sie nicht genau wahrscheinlich
irgendeine mischung aus herzfrequenz geschwindigkeit und geschritt frequenz und
keine ahnung aus was wie garmin das überhaupt errechnet zumindest ist die nie über die ist nie
im plusbereich gewesen heute die schwankte zwischen null und teilweise minus zwei mit
ganz kurz mal bis ganz ganz kurz mal minus minus 4 minus also die schwankte zwischen zwischen minus
zwei zwischen null und minus drei und mal ganz kurz ganz zwei minuten minus vier heute da war
nicht so
nicht so gut eine performance condition so wie viele gigabyte haben einen browser braucht gar
nicht so viel wie man denkt leider guck mal ich habe hier tabs ich habe hier tabs und ich habe
hier noch ein paar tabs und ich habe eigentlich normalerweise sekunde das muss man auch an der
stelle gerade mal machen nicht dass das jetzt nicht dass das unbenutzt bleibt nicht dass das
unbenutzt bleibt der rem der iron champ ist am start
du sitzt hier rum und gar mit meinen stress ich glaube die machen das anhand der leitfähigkeit von
der haut oder so wir machen jetzt mal kurz package update schadet nicht so und jetzt können wir gucken
wie viel ram usage ich habe jetzt nehme ich die vm auf und ich habe ram usage wie nur ist ja nix 18
gigabyte und ich habe 64 gigabyte ram ach ja ich habe übrigens meinen ram runter getaktet wieder
ich habe ja ok ram aber mein rechner ist jetzt die letzten paar wochen ab und an mal gepluscreent und da habe ich meinen ram wieder auf normale taktraten zurück getaktet ja guckt euch das mal an ich habe ja wofür brauche ich den ganzen ram eigentlich 20 gigabyte von 67 man das ist ja kacke komplett umsonst
ja genau ich habe xmp
xmp ja das das zeug habe ich ausgeschaltet auf den normalen takt gestellt also ich meine ich habe im endeffekt die raten ausgewählt mit denen ich den ram gekauft habe aber es ist immerhin noch oc ram ja wer weiß wie genau die das getestet haben ganz ehrlich die performance einbußen so zwischen dem takt und dem normalen takt und dem xmp takt die sind ja wirklich zu vernachlässigen und wenn es wirklich daran liegt dass mein rechner deswegen
ab und zu mal gecrasht ist dann lasse ich lieber runter getaktet ist ja nicht als wäre der schlechter so großartig schlecht dadurch jetzt auf einmal paul dankeschön hast du vier riegel drinnen ne oder ich weiß es gar nicht ne ne ne glaube ich nicht moment moment können wir kurz gucken geizhals moment ich habe übrigens gestern neues video aufgenommen
hallo leute
jetzt muss ich nachher freischalten hier geizhals mein pc ich habe zwei riegel
zweimal 32
hier haben wir dem bauer ein bisschen geld überwiesen
indirekt
weil es ist ja ist das nicht die ist ist thermal grizzly ist da nicht da ist eigentlich der bauer irgendwie noch dran beteiligt
der der auer
der acht auer
yep
ich bilde mir ein das hat was gebracht
dass dadurch mit die cpu ein paar gerade grad
kräde gerade
pack
ja wie heißt das richtig
da
dass dann die CPU ein paar Grad, Grad kälter ist.
Schon mal überlegt, ECC-RAM zu verwenden auf dem Desktop.
Ja, überlegt, aber auf dem Desktop nicht.
Muss ja auch Mainboard was, was unterstützt.
Weiß ich nicht, wie es da mit dem Support aussieht.
Außerdem gibt es ECC-RAM denn mit RGB?
Ich würde vermuten, ECC-RAM und RGB tritt nicht so oft zusammen auf.
Also wenn es RGB-ECC-RAM gäbe, weil RGB-RAM ist enorm wichtig.
Ich habe deswegen extra ein Fenster in meinem Computer drin, in das ich reingucken kann.
Das Dumme ist nur, dass das Fenster zugestellt ist vom anderen Rechner.
Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas.
Du meinst bei der Bahn?
Ja, unmittelbar. Für mich ist der Streik ein Problem.
Aber vor den Hintergründen, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus,
dass es eine klassische Bahnmischung ist.
Verkackt die letzten 15 Jahre über.
Auf Management-Ebene, auf Regierungsebene, auf Gesamtheit.
Das Ding ist einfach so ein Drecksladen.
Tschüssi, Bro, danke für den Sub.
Ich bin nicht mit T-Shirt gerannt.
Ich habe einfach die Arme hochgekrempelt.
Oh, danke für den Sub.
So, excellent.
Ich muss mal kurz ins Creator-Dashboard gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwelche Leute übersehen habe.
Nope.
Pogu.
Okay, dann mal gucken, ob das...
Oh, was muss ich machen?
Ach ja, okay, bestätigen.
Ja, ich dachte, wir machen mal eine Runde Package-Updates.
Package-Updates ist nicht verkehrt.
Was sagen die Jetbrains-Dinger?
Brauchen die auch ein Update?
Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
Die Playlist kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
So, Jetbrains-Gedöns gibt es auch Updates.
Wisst ihr, was mir letztens aufgefallen ist?
Wir verwenden ja öfters Rider hier, um C-Sharp zu developen.
Ist euch eigentlich klar, dass wir .NET mit Java-Unterbau entwickeln?
Damit?
Damit.
Weil das ist eine Jetbrains-IDE, die ist immer in Java.
Das ganze Zeug, das ganze Jetbrains-Zeug ist in Java programmiert.
Das heißt, wir verwenden eine in Java entwickelte IDE, um .NET zu entwickeln.
Nicht, dass das schlimm wäre, ja, das funktioniert.
Oder bei Go oder bei Python, genau das Gleiche.
Das ist halt alles der gleiche Java-Kern.
Daran sieht man, dass Java einfach überlegen ist, ja.
Java einfach der klassische Giga-Chat-Move.
Wobei Java, wie es der Chef angeguckt hat, im englischsprachigen Bereich sagen die eigentlich alle Java.
Oder auch JavaScript.
Hast du dich eigentlich für die Twitch später für AV1-Streaming angemeldet?
Nö.
Ihr wisst, wie motiviert ich immer bin, mich bei Sachen anzumelden, ne?
Lieber C-Sharp mit Java, als mit Microsoft-Produkten entwickeln.
So doof das klingt, das ist tatsächlich so.
Das ist eigentlich lustig, ne?
Wenn du dir überlegst, du benutzt eine Microsoft-Technologie, ein Framework von Microsoft, eine Runtime von Microsoft,
ein komplettes Ökosystem von Microsoft, aber die IDE suckt, die nicht von Microsoft.
Wenn man ehrlich sagen muss, so schlecht ist Visual Studio auch nicht.
Das Problem, Leute, wisst ihr, was das Problem an Visual Studio ist?
Wer kommt drauf?
Ich nicht, Visual Studio.
Was ist das Problem an Visual Studio?
Visual Studio selbst ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das Problem ist, dass Visual Studio unter Windows läuft.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Weil Softwareentwicklung unter Windows, da hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Da gibt es übrigens eine lustige Story von der Arbeit.
Während ich hier mal meine VM reboote, erzähle ich euch das mal kurz.
Und zwar, bei mir auf der Arbeit, ich arbeite in Frankfurt bei einer Versicherung.
Da ist ja alles so super krass secure.
Abgesichert.
So, und es ist ja so, wir haben, nur mal so ganz grob, dass ihr ungefähr eine Ahnung von habt, wie das aufgebaut ist.
Es gibt ein Kubernetes Cluster in der Google Cloud.
Und das ist ein extra Cluster, den wir aufgebaut haben, dass die Entwickler dort quasi auch außerhalb von ihrer lokalen Kiste
mal den Zusammenspiel der gesamten Softwarekomponenten testen können.
Also da kannst du quasi wild deployen, wie du willst.
Im Endeffekt.
So.
Jetzt das Ding.
Die Entwickler bekommen eine Entwickler-VM.
Die Entwickler-VM ist irgendeine Kiste, auf die du per Remote Desktop zugreifst.
Nicht irgendwie etwa lokal oder so auf dem Notebook, wo alles ist.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Die bekommen eine Entwickler-VM.
So, und jetzt gibt es manche Entwickler, die connecten sich nicht von ihrem vom Arbeitgeber zur Verfügung gestellten Notebook.
Auf diese Entwickler-VM.
Sondern benutzen einen Remote-Zugang.
Heißt im Endeffekt, die gehen dann per Remote auf diese VM.
Also es ist dann quasi schon mal ein Remote-Programm, um sich dort auf eine VM zu gehen.
Also Remote auf eine VM.
Und von dort, von ihrer Entwickler-VM, kommen sie aber nirgendswohin.
Dafür haben sie da ihre IDE und alles mögliche, was sie so brauchen.
Ja, die haben da auch zum größten Teil Jetbrains Zeug.
Manche, ich verstehe es ja ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Manche Leute, ist ja hauptsächlich auch Java, weil Business Enterprise.
Manche Leute benutzen Eclipse.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, dass es wirklich Entwickler gibt, die Eclipse verwenden?
Was ist das für ein cooles ASCII-Quarium, ja.
ASCII-Quarium ist das.
Es gibt manche Leute, die verwenden 2024 gerne noch Eclipse.
Oh Leute, ich muss das Update nochmal machen, fällt mir auf.
Keck, wait, ich bin Kack-Noob.
Ich muss Snapshots von gestern reverten.
Snapshots löschen.
Und ich erzähle euch in der Zwischenzeit weiter, während ich das mache.
Weil ich da Mist installiert habe.
Da kann ich gleich nochmal Eclipse installieren und wir können es mal aufmachen.
Wartet mal, Sekunde.
Weil ich wollte Hollywood installieren für die Videoaufnahme.
Ähm, Eclipse.
Gibt es das Ding?
Eclipse.
Guck mal, das gibt es doch nicht mal mehr.
Das gibt es doch nicht mal mehr in den offiziellen Paketquellen zu installieren, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, verstehe ich auch, so ein Schrott.
Will ja auch keiner.
Keck, keckel, Alter.
Keck, wait.
Okay.
So, Snapshots.
Jetzt machen wir, jetzt machen wir Pac-Man-Updates.
Dann rebooten wir nochmal.
Machen wir das gleiche, was wir eben auch gemacht haben.
Toolbox.
Hallo?
Ja, updaten.
Ja, also wie gesagt.
Es gibt Leute, die verwenden allen Ernstes noch freiwillig Eclipse.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Zumindest.
Um die, um die Story, äh, äh, long story short.
Das heißt, die greifen sich.
Das heißt, die greifen schon mal per Remote auf ihre Entwickler-VM zu.
Von dieser Entwickler-VM.
Da haben sie zwar ihre ganzen IDEs und sonst was.
Kommen sie aber nirgends wohin.
Weil alles super krass highly secure.
Aber die wollen ja ihre Anwendung nicht nur lokal testen.
Die wollen ihre Anwendung ja auch quasi bauen und dann im Kubernetes-Cluster testen, um das Zusammenspiel zwischen allem anderen gescheit mal testen zu können.
Okay.
Jetzt ist das Problem.
Jetzt müssen sie von ihrer Entwickler-VM.
Entwickler-VM.
Auf.
Irgendwie.
Sich in die Cloud connecten können.
Damit sie das Ganze.
Dort ausprobieren können.
Das Deployment der Software in den Kubernetes-Cluster.
Das müssen die nicht selbst machen.
Das geht über.
Ich glaube irgendeine GitLab-Pipeline ist das.
Aber um dort was auszuprobieren und zu gucken, wie sich das verhält und so.
Da müssen sie irgendwie an den Kubernetes-Cluster dran.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Weil alles so super secure ist.
Der Weg ist so ultra abgedreht.
Und es ist auch kein offizieller Weg in dem Sinn.
Das ist ein Weg, den ich mir und eins, zwei andere Entwickler ausgedacht habe.
Und zwar.
Als erstes.
Verbinden die sich remote.
Auf ihre Entwickler-VM.
So.
Auf der Entwickler-VM.
Installieren sie sich das Google Cloud SDK.
Weil dort dann das Google Cloud.
Command Line Tool drinne ist.
Was man braucht um sich quasi zu authentifizieren gegen die Google Cloud.
Das Ding ist jetzt.
Du kannst das Google Cloud SDK nicht installieren.
Ratet mal Chatge.
Warum du das Google Cloud SDK nicht installieren kannst.
Also mit dem.
Du lädst dir den offiziellen für Windows Google Cloud SDK Installer runter.
Du kannst es nicht installieren.
Ratet mal warum.
Eventuell ist einer Big Brain und kennt sich im Business Enterprise Umfeld aus.
Und kann erraten.
Woran das liegt.
Dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ich gebe euch so lange Zeit wie Paket Updates.
Läuft es euch was zu überlegen.
Wer richtig liegt gewinnt nen Sub.
Software Restriction Policies.
Nein.
Die sind Admin.
Muss man sagen.
Die Leute haben Admin.
Die haben Admin Rechte auf ihren Entwickler-VMs.
Auf die Idee sind sie auch schon gekommen.
Dass es sonst suckt.
Eierwoll.
Nee.
Aber das geht.
Ungefähr in die Richtung.
Active Directory.
Nein.
Andere MAC Adresse.
Ja es ist schwer drauf zu kommen.
Es ist schwer drauf zu kommen.
Aber.
Vielleicht hat ja einer noch ne zündende Idee.
Ich sag es euch gleich.
Wenn das Paket Update durch ist.
Und wenn ich rebooted habe.
Andere MAC Adresse.
Ist auch nicht.
Active Directory.
DNS.
Nein.
DNS ist auch nicht schuld.
Virenscanner oder kein Internet.
Nein.
Man hat Internet Zugriff.
Virenscanner ist es auch nicht.
Fonts.
Nee.
Man darf kein eigenes Interface an.
Braucht man dafür nicht.
Nee.
Hab Web Application.
Custom Enterprise.
Haben wir.
Aber dafür braucht man das nicht.
Ich sag es euch.
Ausgehender Traffic wird blockiert.
Nee.
Ich.
Ja.
Oh nein.
Ich sag es.
SSL Zeit.
Ja.
Splixer.
Du bist fast.
Ja.
Leute.
Alter.
Der Chat ist so massive High IQ.
Chat ich bin stolz auf euch.
Das ist zwar nicht genau das.
Aber das ist schon sehr.
Das ist schon nah genug dran.
Okay.
Ihr kriegt.
Das Splixer hat schon einen Sub.
Dem kann ich jetzt keinen geben.
Aber.
Dem Dungeon.
Dem kann ich einen Sub giften.
Jetzt.
Siehste mal.
Das ist die erste High IQ.
Erste Message.
Und dann gleich Big Brain Message.
Ja.
Ich agree.
Um mir selbst 3,99 Euro zu überweisen.
Massive.
Richtig.
SSL Inspection.
Und zwar.
Die kommen ins Internet von dort.
Allerdings nur.
Über so einen Man in the Middle Geschichte.
Ja.
Proxy.
Das war nicht spezifisch genug.
Das nur über so eine Man in the Middle SSL Inspection Geschichte.
Und das Ding ist jetzt.
Dass.
Der Google Cloud SDK Installer.
Das basiert auf Python.
Das ganze Google Cloud SDK der Installer auch.
Der verwendet nicht den System eigenen Trust Store für Zertifikate.
Das heißt.
Der Installer trusted nicht dem Zertifikat.
Das SSL Man in the Middle Dings.
So.
Das macht nur Probleme.
Das ist der größte Bullshit ever.
Das heißt.
Sie müssen sich das Google Cloud SDK runterladen.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Dann müssen Sie das entpacken.
Den Installer.
Und müssen in den Trust Store.
Das Embedded Python für den Installer.
Das Zertifikat reinpatchen.
Dann können Sie den Installer ausführen.
Dann können Sie das Ganze starten.
Dann können Sie einen G-Cloud Login machen.
login machen dann können sie cube ctl nach installieren dann muss noch ein
proxy gesetzt werden und dann können sie sich mit cube ctl port forward jetzt
kommt der hit dann können sie sich mit cube ctl anmelden am kubernetes cluster
und können mit cube ctl port forward sich auf einen pod connecten im
kubernetes cluster okay soweit so und dieser pod im kubernetes im moment
leute so einfach ist das nicht so einfach ist das nicht nein nein nein
das ist doch noch leute ihr denkt das war es schon das geht erst richtig los
das geht erst richtig los das geht erst richtig los das war es noch lange nicht
kann man nicht manuell dem einen cluster es geht nicht ums cluster es geht ums
ssl zertifikat
es ging erst mal darum dass du die command line tools installiert bekommst
wie du brauchst um nicht zum cluster zu connecten so und dieser pod auf den du
nicht connecten kannst du machst dann du machst dann quasi cube ctl auf vm starte
please blitz also wer denkt dass es das schon gewesen ist kek wait alter vm
please starten ja okay alles klar so und dieser pod auf das sie machen dann das
wollte ich machen ein cube ctl port forward so was hier in der richtung
machen die dann guckt so was hier sinngemäß so was in der richtung die
machen port forwarding auf auf einen pod kann es auch ein service machen aber
letztendlich kommt auch ein pod raus also es geht nie auf den service auch wenn
man das hier angeben kann kommt man kommt noch ein pod raus kann sagen ich möchte
den lokalen port sowieso auf den pod sowieso weiterleiten so das heißt die
können sich mit cube ctl port forward auf den pod connecten im kubernetes cluster dieser pod im kubernetes cluster
ist ein pod beziehungsweise in dem pod läuft ein container image korrekterweise
müsste man sagen in dem pod läuft ein container mit einem image das ich gebaut
habe und dieses image ist ein minimal debian mit nur einem ssh server und einem
user mit einem den entwicklern bekannten passwort das heißt die können sich dann
quasi auf einen ssh server im name im ip adressbereich der kubernetes pods
eine verbindung mit cube ctl port forward aufmachen dann also die machen dann
quasi so was hier in der richtung ich zeige es euch mal so sinngemäß machen
dann port forward dann wissen wir irgendwie keine ahnung irgendwie dev
container ja das brauchen wir nicht port port local port 22 22 auf port 22 ok so
was in der richtung führen die dann aus und jetzt kommt der hit nachdem sie ja
dann weiter von dort auf die andere cloud infrastruktur müssen zum beispiel
haben wir eine message queue
stehen wo sie sich hin verbinden müssen müssen sie jetzt wiederum einen reverse
ssh tunnel machen über diesen port vor ort und ein pott auf den endpunkt
beispielsweise von der message das heißt danach machen sie sowas hier ja
so was hier in der richtung ja also dann kommt dann quasi lokal porta 88 88 denkt
euch mal das hier ist der end das denkt euch das ist die ip von message server
loku auch weiter auf dort port 88 88 und das ist dann vor dem boot vor dem port
und das ist dann vor dem boot vor dem port vor dem boot vor dem port vor dem port
ist die ip von der msg server lockt auf weiter auf dort port 88 88 und das
Das Ganze geht dann über die SSH-Verbindung auf Localhost Port 2222.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Und dann haben sie lokal eine Verbindung zur Message-Queue aufgebaut.
Logisch, oder?
So, und das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass das an sich alleine auch noch nicht ausreicht.
Weil die Verbindung zur Message-Queue an sich ist ja auch noch nicht alles.
Und letztens kam ein Entwickler zu mir und meinte, ey Max, ich würde gerne debuggen eine unserer Anwendungen, die im Cluster läuft.
Weil im Cluster verhält sich die Anwendung anders als bei ihm auf dem Rechner.
Und jetzt wurde es besonders abenteuerlich.
Jetzt wurde es super abenteuerlich.
Und zwar läuft da halt ein Deployment in Kubernetes und gegen das aktuelle Image von ihm, was er da deployed hat.
Das Problem ist jetzt.
Das Problem ist nur, dass natürlich in diesem Image, wie das gebaut wird, der Debug-Port, um sich da mit IntelliJ zum Beispiel dran zu connecten, überhaupt nicht offen ist.
Das heißt, das erste, was wir gemacht haben, ist kubectl edit von dem Deployment.
Blub, ich kann euch das jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich hier nichts laufen habe.
Edit von dem Deployment.
Dort habe ich erstmal eingetragen, Environment-Variable.
Da gibt es irgendeinen Artikel, keine Ahnung.
Da muss man dann so ganz spezielle...
Ja, so Dinger braucht man dann.
Ja, okay.
Dann habe ich dann quasi das Deployment editiert in Kubernetes.
Das hat eine neue Environment-Variable hinzugefügt.
Mit diesem Geschiss hier drinnen.
Genau so sieht, so sah das aus.
So was muss man dann da eintippen.
Dann ist uns aufgefallen, dass der Entry-Point in dem Container-Image die Environment-Variable gar nicht ausgelesen hat.
Das heißt, ich habe im Deployment nochmal den Entry-Point, also das Command überschrieben.
Was der eigentlich ausführt.
Der hat dann quasi eine Shell gestartet, hat die Variable dort interpoliert und hat dann Java gestartet.
Da drinnen.
So.
Dann hatten wir einen Containerlauf im Kubernetes-Cluster mit dem Debug-Port offen.
Jetzt musste der allerdings an den Debug-Port drankommen.
Das heißt, da bringt ihm dieser Container ja nichts.
Der musste irgendwie sich Port-Forwarden dann auf diesen Container.
Ey, Leute.
Zumindest hat es am Ende funktioniert.
Und er konnte sich mit IntelliJ anschauen.
Und er konnte sich an den Container verbinden.
Super abartig weirdes Zeug.
Wir machen uns da mittlerweile schon lustig drüber, dass halt die einfachsten Sachen bei uns in der Versicherung dreimal so lang dauern,
weil du die ganzen Arbeitsverhinderungsmaßnahmen irgendwie umschiffen musst.
Die Frage ist halt, was bringen diese ganzen Security-Maßnahmen, wenn du sie ja doch umgehen kannst, außer dass sie dich abfacken.
Man weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind dann irgendwelche Leute happy.
Aber die Entwickler sind jetzt glücklich, dass wir einen Weg gefunden haben, das zu machen.
Ist schon echt abenteuerlich, oder?
Also teilweise müssen unsere Entwickler zwei bis drei Tunnel aufbauen, damit sie überhaupt ihre Sachen dann ausprobieren können.
Außer halt lokal.
Lokal auf ihrer Entwicklerkiste geht das.
Aber wie debugst du was, was sich beim ersten Deployment anders verhält als bei dir lokal?
Genau dafür sind ja Container da.
Und nachdem das Windows ist, ist ja auch nichts mit Docker-Container-Staten oder so.
Ja, es ist super, super weird.
Hat das vielleicht was mit Zertifizierung?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich hat das mit irgendwelchen Prüfungen und Vorgaben und haste-nicht-gesehen zu tun.
Das ist bei uns so krass bürokratisch, Alter.
Ich bin jetzt ja, ich bin noch kein Jahr da.
Ich bin, naja, im April.
Im April bin ich ein Jahr da.
Erster April.
Sag mal, ich bin zehn Monate oder so jetzt da.
Also Februar, März halt noch.
Also sag mal, ich bin zehn Monate da.
Und ich bin jetzt, ich bin jetzt da wirklich schon, das ist schon Alltag für mich.
Also ich denke nicht mehr an den alten Arbeitgeber.
Für mich ist es vollkommen normal, dass ich da jetzt jeden Tag am Start bin.
Und was man auch daran merkt ist, dass es normal für mich ist.
Es gibt schon genug Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen.
Ja, zum Beispiel das ganze übertrieben bürokratische Zeug.
Ja, Pech gehabt.
Sgt. Silver, danke für den Sub.
Übrigens.
Ich spiele ja aktuell immer noch.
Aktuell immer noch Dark Edge of Camelot auf dem Freeshot.
Und weißt du, was für dort Sgt. steht?
Das steht da für Siege Tower.
Nicht für Sgt.
Fällt mir nur gerade auf.
Weil die Leute schreiben da immer im Chat Sgt. Sgt.
Und das heißt Siege Tower.
Ja, ey, das ist heftig.
Und es ist nicht nur so, dass es einfach just for fun ist.
Du kriegst ja dann auch.
Oh, ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Du kriegst ja dann auch Minuspunkte, wenn du gewisse Sachen.
Quasi verkackst und sowas an Vorgaben.
Da kriegst du richtig Probleme im Zweifelsfall.
Renovate ist mega nice.
Ja.
Der ist halt nicht schön, wenn man einfach Let's Encrypt verwenden könnte.
Was bei uns auch geil ist.
Wisst ihr, was ich gemerkt habe?
So Banken und Versicherungen.
Das war ja, als ich bei der Bank gearbeitet habe.
Ist jetzt bei der Versicherung auch so.
Leute, das ist eine gefundene Geldgrube für Wirtschaftsprüfer.
Wir haben gefühlt.
Keine Ahnung.
Alle namenhaften Wirtschaftsprüfer und.
So Consulting Läden bei uns irgendwie rumschwirren.
Und das ist echt ein so.
Das ist, wie soll man sagen?
Das ist die Lizenz zum Geld drucken für Berater und Prüfer.
So eine Versicherung.
Weil es ist so, dass viele Abläufe dort.
Wie soll man sagen?
Das ist, wie soll man sagen?
Das ist die Lizenz zum Geld drucken für Berater und Prüfer.
So eine Versicherung.
Weil es ist so, dass viele Abläufe dort.
Wie soll man sagen?
Die müssen nicht unbedingt immer geprüft werden.
Aber es ist immer quasi.
Es wird immer gerne gesehen, dass das geprüft ist.
Und das läuft dann so.
Das läuft dann so.
Dass es irgendeinen neuen Ablauf gibt.
Und dann sagt dann der Wirtschaftsprüfer.
Ah, den würden wir aber gerne überwachen.
Und den würden wir uns gerne angucken.
Und die Versicherung sagt dann.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
Macht ihr mal.
Weil es für die Versicherung gut ist, sagen zu können.
Der Wirtschaftsprüfer war dabei.
Oder der Prüfer war dabei.
Oder der Prüfer ist das einfach.
Komplett die Lizenz zum Geld drucken.
Die kriegen für jeden Scheiß richtig fett Kohle.
Den sie da machen.
Und die sagen bei jedem Furz.
Ah, da wären wir gerne dabei.
Und die Versicherung findet es geil, dass die dabei sind.
Weil dann können sie sagen.
Wir wurden geprüft.
Das ist mega.
Das ist Ultralizenz zum Geld drucken.
Aber jetzt auch lokal eine richtige Domain mit TLS.
Ja, exzellent, exzellent.
Das ist ein separates Netz.
Die VMs sind in einem eigenen Netz.
Und die Clowninfrastruktur ist in einem anderen Netz.
Aber trotzdem müssen die da irgendwie hinkommen.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal schauen.
Was trendet denn auf Shithub?
Wo ist eigentlich mein Wasserglas?
Wo ist denn das hin?
Die Wasserflasche habe ich da.
Die Synthetik habe ich noch da.
Aber das Glas ist weg.
Warte mal, Question.
Wie lange würdest du sagen, hat jemand zum Einarbeiten.
Moment, Moment.
Ich bin zu braindead gerade.
Was möchtest du mir sagen? Was?
Wie lange würdest du sagen,
hat jemand zum Einarbeiten.
Achso.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Wie lange würdest du sagen, hat jemand zum Einarbeiten.
Oder nach welcher Zeit wird welche Leistung.
Also jemand der nach dem Studium kommt.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich kann dir sagen, wie lange du Zeit hast.
Dich einzuarbeiten.
Wenn du irgendwo neu anfängst.
Solange du brauchst.
Blöde Antwort.
Ich weiß.
Aber in großen.
Und komplizierter das Unternehmen ist.
Ist die Einarbeitung nie abgeschlossen.
Leute die 20 Jahre da sind.
Hören neue Abkürzungen.
Und neue Dinge und sowas.
Die Einarbeitung ist nie fertig.
Solange du brauchst.
Bist du sicher.
Bist in den Sachen die du machen musst.
Also.
Nehmen wir das doch mal bei mir als Beispiel.
Ich bin jetzt 10 Monate da.
Ich würde sagen ich blick mittlerweile ganz gut durch.
Aber ich höre an laufende.
An jeder Ecke noch Dinger.
Weil ich keinen Plan habe was das ist.
Und ich weiß dass es Leuten die 20 Jahre da sind.
Genauso geht.
Da habe ich mich nicht dran gehalten.
Ich habe am Anfang.
Bei jeder zweiten Sache gefragt.
Warum machen wir das eigentlich so.
Und da war die Antwort oftmals drauf.
So nach dem Motto.
Ja weil es historisch gewachsen ist.
Nicht weil es Sinn macht.
Ich habe zum Beispiel.
Letztens habe ich gesagt.
Wollen wir nicht TMAX und Hardtop auf alle Linux Server drauf machen.
Und da meinten die Leute. Oh ne.
Warum nicht.
Das ist doch mega praktisch.
Gerade TMAX kannst du aus dem Hintergrund laufen lassen.
Ja ne aber.
Und dann habe ich erfahren.
Eigentlich finden sie die Idee auch gut.
Aber dann müssten sie irgendwie.
Einen neuen Base Package Antrag stellen.
Und hast du nicht gesehen.
Und habe ich gesagt.
Wisst ihr was.
Auf allen Kisten die wir jetzt neu aufbauen.
Und die in der Cloud sind.
Und wo wir das sagen haben.
Machen wir das einfach.
Darauf geschissen.
Weil auf unseren Cloud Kisten.
Können wir ein bisschen mehr machen was wir wollen.
Da brauchen wir keinen Basisfreigabe Package.
Was auch immer Antrag.
Um TMAX installieren zu können.
Und da hatte wirklich jemand gemeint.
Max jedes Binary bietet Angriffsfläche.
Ja ist klar.
Ist klar.
Was willst du denn dagegen sagen.
Warum ist überhaupt eine Shell installiert.
Du kannst doch jedes mal.
Erst mal einen Package Install laufen lassen.
Wenn du dich Remote einloggen lassen musst.
Also eine vorinstallierte Shell.
Bietet eh enorm viel Angriffsfläche.
Dass da überhaupt SSH offen ist.
Bietet auch Angriffsfläche.
Warum ist da überhaupt ein fucking.
Warum ist da ein Betriebssystem drauf.
Leute.
Warum ist das nicht.
Bare Metal bootet direkt in die Anwendung.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Alles bloated und Angriffsfläche.
Warum ist das.
Warum hat das überhaupt einen Netzwerkstecker drin.
Und ist überhaupt eingeschaltet.
Man könnte es doch nur einschalten.
Wenn jemand drauf zugreifen möchte.
Nur über Konsolenkabel wird nur noch.
Nur serielle Verbindung.
Alles andere ist bloat.
Ich zeig dir was T-Max ist.
T-Mux.
Zeig dir was das ist.
Eigentlich was ganz nices.
Und zwar.
Ich habe hier meine Shell wo ich tippen kann.
Jetzt überleg dir mal.
Ich bin nicht lokal bei mir.
Sondern ich bin auf einem Server drauf.
Ich erstelle mal kurz eine VM.
Stellt euch vor.
Das wäre jetzt ein Server der bei.
Bei Hetzner oder.
Google, Microsoft.
Azure.
AWS.
DigitalOcean.
Netcup was auch immer läuft.
So.
Ich bin jetzt remote eingeloggt auf meinem Server.
In der Cloud.
Und jetzt möchte ich dort.
Ein paar Sachen ausführen die ein bisschen länger brauchen.
Und will mir Logs angucken dabei.
Also würde ich sagen.
Gucke ich mir als erstes mal Log an.
Warlogmessages.
Oder ne gibt es ja nicht mehr so ein Log.
Fuck was gibt es da überhaupt noch.
Ok.
Was zum Teufel gibt es.
Achso ich bin nicht root.
Warlog.
So.
Ich habe nichts drauf.
Ok.
Genau das wollte ich mir unbedingt angucken.
Achso das ist.
What the hell.
Ist da nichts drauf.
Ok Cloud in den Output.
Also ich bin da drauf eingeloggt.
Und möchte mir die Datei hier angucken.
Und nebenbei was machen.
Jetzt ist das Problem.
Was muss ich jetzt machen.
Das ich mir die Logdatei angucken kann.
Und nebenbei auf dem Server was machen.
Das sieht man.
Geht nicht weil.
Ich bin eingeloggt und habe hier eine Datei offen.
Das heißt ich muss jetzt die Datei zu machen.
Dann würden wir sagen wir mal ein Programm starten.
Hier drauf. Machen wir.
Wir starten jetzt mal exemplarisch.
Eine Schleife.
Die einfach hier immer 1 ausgibt.
So.
Jetzt kann ich aber.
Ich würde gerne das Programm laufen lassen.
Und parallel in die Logs gucken.
Funktioniert nicht.
Ja scheiße war es.
So und jetzt.
Da kommt TMAX ins Spiel.
Up Install TMAX.
Up Update.
Da kommt TMAX ins Spiel.
Jetzt habe ich hier unten so eine Leiste.
Und ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel.
Hier drauf meine Schleife starten.
Ja Steuerung Z Background.
Das ist aber auch kacke.
Viele gehen dann ins Sleep und machen nichts mehr.
Das ist alles Schrott.
Das ist viel besser.
Was ist eine gute Möglichkeit wie man TMAX in TMAX handeln kann.
Also wenn du TMAX lokal hast.
Ist die beste Möglichkeit dein Modifier Key.
Von Steuerung B auf Steuerung A zu legen.
Dann hast du keine Probleme mehr.
Ansonsten musst du halt doppelt Escapen.
Steuerung BB und sowas.
So jetzt kann ich hier oben zum Beispiel.
Mein Programm starten.
Machen wir exemplarisch mal wieder meine Schleife.
Hier unten.
Ich bin immerhin weiter auf dem Server.
Kann ich mir die.
Die Systemauslastung angucken.
Da kann ich den zweiten.
Da kann ich den zweiten Tab aufmachen.
Hier machen wir.
Beispielsweise noch die.
Systemauslastung auf.
So.
Inklusive IO.
Und jetzt bin ich immer auf dem gleichen Server.
Über eine SSH Connection.
Und.
Ich kann aber mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig machen.
Und wisst ihr was das.
Wisst ihr was das richtig coole an TMAX ist.
Ja.
Was haben wir hier machen wir jetzt noch.
Hier machen wir jetzt.
Moment.
Jetzt haben wir super krasse Überwachung.
Von unserem eins ausgebenden Programm hier oben.
Das brauchen wir unbedingt.
So jetzt habe ich drei Sachen parallel laufen.
Und ich kann jetzt feststellen.
Ach Mist.
Ich wollte doch gerade noch mal hier nach den Logs gucken.
Ich brauche eine Stelle.
Schnell mache ich ein neues Tab in TMAX auf.
Geh nach war Log.
Und guck mir an was hier so abgeht.
Also es ist enorm praktisch.
Und jetzt kommt.
Und jetzt kommt das beste an TMAX.
Jetzt bricht eure Verbindung ab.
Oder ihr geht heim.
Und dieser.
Geht mal davon aus hier oben läuft ein Skript.
Aber ihr wollt jetzt euer Laptop mit heim nehmen.
Oder ihr geht heim und loggt euch aus.
Fahrt runter.
Musst Wartung machen.
Normalerweise würde es jetzt abkacken.
Weil eure SSH Verbindung abkackt.
Nicht so sehr.
Wenn ihr jetzt TMAX verwendet.
TMAX könnt ihr euch einfach detachen.
Ausloggen aus der VM.
Ihr seht ich bin wieder lokal.
Ich habe meine SSH.
Meine SSH Verbindung ist zu.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Stehe morgen früh wieder auf.
Was macht eigentlich diese 40 Stunden Auswertung.
Dann connecte ich mich wieder.
Per SSH drauf.
Sagt TMAX A.
Attach mich an die schon bestehende TMAX Session.
Und kann an der Stelle weiter machen.
Und schon sind wir wieder hier.
Also TMAX ist enorm praktisch.
Und ich installiere es jetzt einfach auf jedem Server.
Auf dem ich mich connecte nach.
Da brauche ich keinen Basic Package.
Approval Prozess.
Was auch immer.
Ich installiere es einfach nach.
Das interessiert keinen.
Und schon sind wir wieder.
Attach und alles gut.
Ja das scheint sehr gut zu sein.
Ist Screen.
Ja aber Screen ist abfuck.
Gegen TMAX.
Ich glaube in Screen.
Das einzige was du in Screen machen kannst.
Ist Attach und Detach.
Von dem was ich euch gezeigt habe.
Kannst du bitte deine TMAX Config.
In ein .Files Repo packen.
Ich habe keine TMAX Config mehr.
Das ist die Default TMAX Config hier.
Ich meine ich habe die VM gerade erst gestartet.
Das ist die ganz normale Default Config.
Sonst ist da nichts.
Hier ist nichts.
Das ist die ganz normale Default Config.
Oder meinst du das hier unten?
Das hier unten ist kein TMAX.
Das hier unten ist mein Terminal.
Mein Terminal kann ähnliche Sachen wie TMAX.
Nur das es halt das Terminal kann.
Das kann auch Splitten.
Wenn ich die richtige Taste drücke.
Das kann Zoom einzelne Paints.
Kannst unterschiedliche anklicken.
Kannst mehrere Tabs aufmachen.
Das ist aber mein Terminal hier unten.
Meine alte TMAX Config findest du aber hier.
Die habe ich noch irgendwo unter Repos.
Old.Files
TMAX Config
Das war aber auch alles schon.
Das einzige was ich da drin hatte.
Das war als ich TMAX noch lokal verwendet habe.
Auf Servern selbst habe ich nie eine spezielle TMAX Config.
Sondern immer Default.
Also hier habe ich auch nichts großartiges gehabt.
Ich habe ein bisschen Farben gesetzt.
Und die einzigen zusätzlichen.
Das du scrollen kannst habe ich hochgestellt.
Und das einzige was ich wirklich ein bisschen customised habe ist.
Die meist benutzten Shortcuts.
Ich habe zum Beispiel.
Down Left Right Up
Habe ich gemappt auf
Im Endeffekt hier.
Durchschalten zwischen den einzelnen
Caps und zwischen den einzelnen Pains.
Dann habe ich
Ctrl F im zoomen gemappt.
Das es groß wird.
Das gleiche habe ich jetzt bei mir im Terminal auch.
Und ich habe das es langsamer scrollt.
Wenn ich Shift Page abdrücke.
Aber wie gesagt.
Das verwende ich aktuell gar nicht mehr.
Ich verwende nur mein Terminal noch.
Wenn du nicht Tmax in Tmax brauchst.
Workout Champ am Start.
Und auf dem Server nur Default Tmax.
Sonst nichts.
Aber die alte Config ist hier.
Falls dich das Terminal interessiert.
Was ich dir wärmstens nur empfehlen kann.
Das Terminal zu verwenden.
Weil das ein Extremely POG Terminal ist.
Hast du meine Config hier.
West Term.
Heute gibts keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Und wisst ihr was das nice an der Terminal Config ist.
Also hier.
Das Programm was ich hier verwende.
Für mein Command Line.
Das ist eine Lua Config.
Klingt jetzt erstmal bescheuert.
Warum ne Config in der Programmiersprache.
Aber das ist mega nice.
Weil du kannst quasi deine Config teilweise dynamisch generieren.
Und ich habe hier sowas gebaut.
Ich weiß das zeige ich immer.
Aber das finde ich super nice.
Ich habe quasi.
Auf meine Maus Buttons gemappt.
Egal wie oft ich die Maus Buttons drücke.
Dass der immer die gleichen Sachen wiederholt.
Guck.
Also ich kann meinen Maus Button 1-99 Mal klicken.
Und er macht dann immer das gleiche.
Zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich einen Streak habe.
Einen Mausklick Streak.
Von Maus Button Down.
Und zwar den mittleren Maus Button.
Von 1-99.
Sieht man ja hier Streak I.
Der legt jetzt quasi ne Config an.
Der legt das hier quasi 99 Mal an.
Einmal mit 1.
Zweimal in Folge mittlere Maus Button.
Dreimal in Folge mittlere Maus Button.
Und dann passiert immer Paste Primary Selection.
Das kennt man ja schon.
Na das hat ein bisschen rumgebackt in Westterm.
Ich kann jetzt quasi hier die Sachen.
Egal wie oft ich mittlere Maus Button drücke.
Pasten.
Und auch viel geiler.
Man kann sogar bestimmte Sachen.
Skripten.
Ich weiß das das auch.
Anderweitig geht unter Linux.
Aber ich finde das Verhalten hier beispielsweise ganz nice.
Und zwar was der macht ist.
Was wird heute gemacht.
Eigentlich nur ein bisschen Videos geguckt.
Aufwachen und Github Trends gucken.
Wir gucken uns gerade meine Terminal Config an.
So hier.
Wenn ich den rechten Maus Button drücke.
Dann passiert folgendes.
Der guckt.
Ob Text gerade Selected ist.
Im Terminal.
Also sowas hier.
Wenn Text Selected ist.
Dann bewirkt die mittlere Maus Taste.
Das der Text in die Zwischenablage kopiert wird.
In das Clipboard.
Und in die Primary Selection.
Weil wie ihr ja wisst.
Linux hat 2.
Eigentlich sogar 3 Zwischenablagen.
Dann wird der Text reinkopiert.
Und die Selection entfernt.
Ist keine Selection da.
Fügt die rechte Maus Taste ein.
Heißt im Endeffekt.
Ich kann jetzt sowas hier machen.
Anklicken.
Rechte Maus Taste drücken.
Jetzt ist es in der Zwischenablage.
Und nochmal rechte Maus Taste drücken.
Und jetzt wird es gepastet.
Das heißt ich kann im Endeffekt.
Markieren.
Klick klick mit der rechten Maus Taste.
Und es wird eingefügt.
Im Prinzip ist es das gleiche wie mittlere Maus Taste.
By the way.
Also ähnlich.
Mittlere Maus Taste lässt es markiert.
Ich kann jetzt markieren.
Clipboard.
Wird Markierung entfernt.
Rechts einfügen.
Und dann kann ich die Maus Taste.
Die in einer Programmiersprache erstellen wurde.
Man kann die dynamisch generieren.
Das ist halt sehr nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Also ich war auch eher skeptisch.
Warum die ihre Config in Lua haben.
Aber das ist nice.
Und ansonsten.
Wenn man das nicht machen will.
Mittlere Maus.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht T-Max.
Das ist nur mein Terminal.
Bei T-Max kann es sein.
Und wenn ihr das alles nicht machen wollt.
Könnt ihr auch die Westterm Config.
Mehr oder weniger benutzen.
Wie eine traditionelle Config.
Hier.
Disable Default Key Bindings To.
Paint Focus Follows Maus Falls.
Key Page Up soll das machen.
Page Down Shift soll das machen.
Also das ist jetzt die relativ klassische.
Relativ klassische Config.
Windows Padding.
Das ist hier.
Das ich noch ein bisschen Rand habe.
Das ich.
Also hier links und rechts.
Das ein bisschen Abstand ist.
Seht ihr ja.
Border Frame.
Opacity im Hintergrund.
Man sieht leicht den Hintergrund durchschimmern.
Durch Terminal.
Scroll History.
Und sowas.
Farbschema.
Könnt ihr auch ganz normal konfigurieren.
Aber es ist schon nice.
Das die dynamisch erzeugt werden kann.
Mit Lua die Config.
Ist das.
Ja.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das das Terminal written in Rust ist.
Was würden wir machen.
Wenn unser Terminal nicht Blazingly Fast wäre.
Ach ja Chat.
Heute gibt es keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Wisst ihr was heute zu essen gibt.
Wer weiß es.
Ist nicht schwer.
Ihr kommt drauf.
An alle die öfters da sind.
Bolognese korrekt.
Gibt ja nur zwei Sachen.
Okay was sind denn die GitHub Trends.
Das wollte ich mir seit gefühlt einer Stunde schon angucken.
Open Source Spotify Client.
Excellent.
Written in Dart.
Warum denn Dart.
Weil Flutter oder wie.
Ja weil Flutter.
Flutter.
Nitta ist tot.
Echt warum.
Woher weiß man das.
Dass das tot ist.
Oh ich sehe es gerade auf.
Das heißt Nitta tut nicht mehr.
Wow.
Auf die Seite gehe ich nicht.
Guest Accounts have been removed.
Okay Nitta ist dead.
Das ist aber sehr sadge.
Ne Eclipse gucken wir uns nicht an.
Nitta ist dead.
Ja das ist blöd.
Also Nitta war ein alternativer Twitter Viewer.
Den ich persönlich sehr nice fand.
Weil man das auch gut verwenden konnte.
Um sich nicht einloggen zu müssen.
Naja.
Elon hat zugeschlagen.
Sadge deadge.
Ja das ist kacke.
Hä wie jetzt.
Hat sich irgendjemand die Domain.
fritz.box
registrieren lassen oder wie.
Who is fritz.box
Tatsächlich.
Moment.
Warum hat es noch nicht schon früher jemand gemacht.
Also erstens.
Warum lässt sich das auf einmal registrieren.
Warum ist das jetzt.
Warum ist das jetzt erst.
Warum ist sie jetzt erst.
Gibt es .box erst neu oder was.
Ach die ist erst neu .box Domain.
Ey das ist so dumm.
Das ist genau so dumm wie dieses .zip.
Das war ja klar.
Das ist irgendein Voll Depp.
Wobei das ist kein Voll Depp.
Also der ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau.
Dass er die fritz.box hat registrieren lassen.
Geil super nice.
Und das ist ein .box Domain gibt es.
Hey das ist teilweise.
Frage ich mich echt ob die alle nicht nachdenken.
Bevor sie neue Domains raushauen.
Das ist einfach hängen geblieben.
Ok also irgendjemand hat sich.
fritz.box registriert.
Das heißt wenn ihr jetzt nicht den DNS.
Von eurer fritz.box verwendet.
So dass fritz.box überschrieben wird.
Oder halt ihr das selbst bei euch im DNS eingetragen habt.
Dann landet man jetzt.
Bei fritz.box auf irgendeinem.
NFT Shop Selling Kram.
Wo ist der Typ bei.
Name Silo.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Was kostet kekw.box.
Nicht .com .box.
Warum kann man .box nicht kaufen.
Was kostet x.box.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ok.
Buy Box Domains.
Alter was ist das für ein.
Hyper Hipster Build.
Ok x.box.
x.box ist taken.
Oh.
Aber was ist kekw.
.box.
kekw.box ist taken.
Ok.
Zeigen die einfach nur Mist an.
Was ist das hier .box.
Ist taken.
Ja ganz bestimmt.
Ich glaub es euch sofort.
Sicherlich.
Ganz bestimmt.
Ganz bestimmt ist es taken.
Mit Sicherheit.
Sofort glaube ich euch das.
Also.
.box Domains.
Haben die hier irgendwas.
Discord.
Fucking Discord Server.
The world's first blockchain native DNS.
Ja wo kann man denn.
.box Domains kaufen.
Also da ja anscheinend schon mal nicht.
MyPo. Ok das ist irgendein NFT.
Search for your name.box.
kekw.box.
Bei 120 Dollar.
Ah das ist.
Ok das kann man nur mit Kryptostells bezahlen.
Verstehe.
Wie sieht das aus mit Twitter.box.
Oh ist unavailable. Shit.
Wie sieht das aus.
Mit. Ok xbox.
Playstation.box.
It is available.
Ok.
MaxFPS.box.
Ja das dachte ich mal. Das werde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Wozu. Gibt es Text.box.
Ne andere waren auch schon schlauer.
Ähm.
Twitch.box.
Ah ok.
Available.
Drop.box.
Das haben die sich bestimmt registrieren lassen.
Wobblords.box.
Ja das gibt es.
Interessant.
Kryptowalletstells.
Alles klar.
Was man nicht alles lernt.
Fritz.box. Alter ich fasse es nicht.
Oh Mann.
Ok also ich wollte eigentlich gucken was trendet auf GitHub.
Seit einer Stunde.
Dönerbox.
Ey das ist eine geile Idee. Sekunde.
Ich meine Umlaute. Warum nicht.
Döner.
Oh ne.
Dönerbox gibt es noch.
Chat. Wie macht man Umlaute in der Domain.
Da gibt es doch so eine.
Ehh.
Emoji Domains.
Wie kann man diesen Campbell encoden.
Da gibt es doch so einen.
Unicode Converter.
Das da.
Und jetzt.
Ist frei.
Nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe Chat.
Ich habe das noch nie verwendet.
Wenn ich mir.
Moment das habe ich jetzt irgendwie.
Wenn ich mir das jetzt kaufen würde.
Dann könnte man Döner.box.
Aufrufen oder wie ist das.
Oder muss das der DNS irgendwie umwandeln.
Unterstützen.
Ich habe mich damit noch nie beschäftigt.
Ja es gibt ja auch Emoji Domains.
Und sowas mittlerweile schon.
Nudelbox.
Gibt es das noch.
Ne das will ich nicht.
Ich will nicht Nudelbox.
Ich will Nudel Nudel mit Lachs.
Box.
Ist auch noch frei.
Asia das ist bestimmt schon weg.
Oh.
Achso.
Wie funktioniert das.
Ok man muss sein Wallet connecten.
Coinbase.
Und dann kann man.
Ok da muss man.
Kann man nur mit Krypto Stealth bezahlen anscheinend.
Boah.
Mal überlegen was für eine.box Domain ich mir kaufen kann.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit SaaS.box aus.
Gibt es auch noch.
Ja Leute.
Wird Zeit das wir uns ein Krypto Wallet anlegen.
Und mal eine Runde.
Box Domains kaufen.
So aber was trennt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich auf Github.
Wir kommen da heute echt nicht dazu.
Ja komisches.
Komisches.
AI Zeug.
Raster das kennen wir schon.
AI AI.
AI AI AI.
AI.
Jasoncrack.com.
Innovative und Open Source.
Visualisation Applikation.
Bla bla bla.
GRPC Go.
Das es das in Go gibt.
Hätte es das nicht in Go gegeben.
Hätte mich auch schwer gewundert.
Oh.
IPTV ok.
Bestimmt furchtbar offizielle.
IPTV Stream Links.
Wenn ich das Repo mir so angucke.
Ja nicht so spannend oder.
Lass uns mal ganz schnell noch.
Gucken was es denn in der Dotnet Welt Neues gibt.
Ah ja Afrikaans.
Nein ähm.
Wenn es die Sharp Welt Neues so gibt.
Also was war Expo habe ich jetzt gar nicht.
Open Source Plattform.
Mac Universe.
Das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich das habe ich mir sogar schon mal angeguckt.
War Expo nicht so ein Ding wo du früher.
Einfacher deine React Apps.
Auf ein iPhone sideloaden konntest.
Weil es eine Expo App gab.
Die dann quasi nur deinen Code ausgeführt hat.
Was dann Apple irgendwann entfernt hat.
Wusste gar nicht das es das noch gibt.
Das gibt es noch.
Ok in der Dotnet Welt.
Wieder nichts spannendes.
Also wenn diese Woche Maui wieder trennt.
Glaube ich echt das es geboostet von Microsoft.
Einfach nur.
Ich weiß nicht ob der bei Sinn ist.
Irgendwie Maui benutzt.
Shit Extensions.
Wisst ihr woran erkennt man Noobs.
Noobs erkennt man daran.
Das sie für Git irgendwelche GUI Tools verwenden.
Habe ich schon oft genug gesagt.
Und der Chat ist ja da immer komplett anderer Meinung.
Jetzt kommen gleich.
Jetzt spawnen gleich wieder die Leute im Chat.
Die sagen.
Aber Max ich verwende immer GUI Tools mit Git.
Ich hatte damit noch nie Probleme.
GUI Tools beste.
Aber für mich ist Command Line Git das einzig wahre.
Wo ich es mir gefallen lasse ist.
Beispielsweise vielleicht bei etwas längeren Merch Konflikten.
Das ich sage.
Ja ok da kann man ein GUI Tool verwenden.
Man kann aber auch Wimdiv verwenden.
Chat Merch Konflikte.
Wimdiv oder GUI Tool.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich verwende eigentlich auch nicht Wimdiv.
Weil Wimdiv.
Keine Ahnung Wimdiv checke ich nicht.
Man kann auch Merch Konflikte einfach bei Text Editor von Hand lösen.
Also hier übertreiben das die Dotnet Leute.
Echt richtig.
Ich habe mir mal so einen Vortrag angeguckt.
Zu so einem Clean Architecture Projekt.
Und.
Das war so ultra plaud.
Einfach nur.
Da hat irgendeiner dann.
Ist dann irgendeiner auf die Idee gekommen.
Das man DateTime nicht verwenden darf.
Sondern ein eigenes IDateTime Interface dafür braucht.
Weil DateTime.
Ich denke mir so.
WTF ich meine DateTime ist Standard Framework Library Kram.
Warum sollte man das nicht verwenden.
Also.
Wenn man unbedingt aus.
50 Zeilen 800 Zeilen machen will.
Für kleine Projekte.
Dann kann man ja auch mit Clean Architecture machen.
Ansonsten für größere Sachen ist es natürlich sinnvoll.
Richtig.
Genau sehe ich auch so.
Wenn du größere Sachen hast.
Gerade wenn du Sachen hast wo unterschiedliche Leute im Team.
An unterschiedlichen Sachen.
Macht das halt schon Sinn.
Aber so dieses jedes Projekt was ich erstelle ist nur noch Clean Architecture.
Ist halt bescheuert.
Außerdem ist das eindeutig gemünzt auf Web Anwendungen.
Steht ja sogar da.
Oder Web Backends.
PEAS.
Achso das Zeug da.
Was ist das?
Ist das ein Game?
Ist das irgendein Cheating?
Cheat Menü?
Was bin ich hier sehend Leute?
Ist das.
Ist das irgendein Cheating Tool?
Aber für was?
Was ist das?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht was ich da sehe.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Lethal Company.
Was da kenne ich nicht.
Coop.
Moment das ist ein Multiplayer Game.
Ein Multiplayer Coop Game.
In dem die Leute dann auch noch Cheaten.
Naja gut.
Nachdem es ein Coop Game ist.
Und man sich dann quasi nur sich und seinen Kollegen den Spaß verdirbt.
Wenn man es übertreibt.
Finde ich das okay.
Gerade wenn man mal Sachen ausprobieren will die das nicht so vorsieht.
Glaube das ist nicht so.
Glaube das ist nicht so wild.
Mit Cheats wenn es Singleplayer Games sind.
Coop Games.
Wenn es Competitive Multiplayer Games sind.
Dann ist das natürlich problematisch.
Avalonia trendet.
Zurecht.
Ich hoffe das trendet immer weiter.
Und Maui trendet nicht.
Weil Maui Schrott ist und Avalonia POG.
Open API Based HTTP Client Code Generator.
Ist ja schön.
Problem ist nur das Fiat.
Weil ich muss ja irgendwann auch da mal.
Irgendwann wieder weiterentwickeln.
Fiat natürlich keine Open API Definition hat.
Aber das ist ja gut.
Aber der Gipfel ist ja super.
Und ich muss sagen.
Ich bin schon sehr happy.
Ja genau.
3 Stunden Design Patterns und Best Practice Patterns.
Und hast du nicht gesehen.
Damit der Hello World laufen ist.
Okay.
Also.
Gucken wir uns mal ein paar Videos an.
Wir sind jetzt fast 1 Stunde 45 auf.
Ich habe ohne Pause dummes Zeug geschwätzt.
Gucken wir uns jetzt mal ein paar Witz an.
Gaming-Stream ohne Leck, Moonlight, Sunshine im Test.
Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Schon vor Jahren.
Das gibt es ja schon eine ganze Weile.
Was ist eigentlich mit den Shorts wieder los?
Wisst ihr, ich bin...
Also es gibt zwei Sachen, die mag ich nicht, was so Emotes angeht.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die hasse ich regelrecht.
Das eine sind Clown-Emojis.
Clown-Emojis sind einfach in so vielen Bereichen negativ vorbehalten.
Sobald ich ein Clown-Emoji sehe, gucke ich mir das nicht an.
So.
Und wisst ihr, was das andere ist, was ich nicht mag?
In Chats.
Es gibt zwei Sachen.
Clown-Emoji mag ich nicht.
Ja, ist klar, dass der Chat jetzt wieder loslegen muss.
Clown-Emojis mag ich nicht.
Und was ich auch nicht mag, ist...
Den da.
Ich kann diesen Smiley...
Ich kann ihn...
Nicht die Twitch-Variante.
Die Twitch-Variante geht ja noch.
Ich kann diesen in genau dieser Variante...
Ich kann ihn nicht ab.
Widerlich, ne?
Chat, ich hab...
Okay.
Wir müssen eine ganz...
Wir müssen eine ganz wichtige...
Ganz wichtige Umfrage machen.
Was ist...
Was ist schlimmer?
Ich mach mal eine Umfrage.
Clown vs. Zwinker-Smiley.
YouTube-Emojis sind einfach nur schlecht.
Alter, der Windows 11 Clown-Smiley sieht da schon ein bisschen gestört aus, oder?
Ich...
Den mag ich.
Den benutze ich selbst.
Auch...
Gerne.
Ich lerne gerade...
Was?
Für die Uni und die Unterricht noch immer Netzwerklassen.
Hast du die jemals in freier Wildbahn gesehen?
Ja.
Es ist ja heute zum größten Teil Zitre.
Aber im Prinzip spielen sich die privaten Sachen ja immer noch in den dafür vorgesehenen privaten Netzen ab.
Auch wenn du nicht hardcodet immer nur...
Slash...
24...
Dings...
Aber...
Ja.
Doch eigentlich...
So eigentlich...
Also zumindest zu wissen, von wo bis wo...
Private IP-Ranges sind, ist doch nicht verkehrt.
Ich seh's anders.
Ich find den auch scheiße, aber der regt mich am allermeisten auf.
Ich kann das nicht ab...
Letzt...
Beispiel.
Letztens Chat in einem MMO gehabt.
Ja.
Leute, join in die Gruppe.
Ich weiß, das ist ein Deutscher.
Und ich schreib in Chat...
Und was antwortet er darauf?
Was soll die scheiß Antwort, Mann?
Das triggert mich ultra.
Das ist...
Ich hasse diesen Smiley einfach nur.
Das ist so...
Ich krieg immer Anfälle, wenn ich den seh in irgendeinem Chat.
Was ist...
Was ist das für eine Antwort auf Moin, Mann?
Soll er lieber...
Soll er die Klappe halt und nix schreiben?
Zwinker.
Ich kann das...
Da kannst du so viel reininterpretieren.
Aber ich interpretier da immer nur das Negativste rein.
Ah.
Chat.
Hab ich...
Vergessen.
Wo waren wir grad stehen geblieben?
Keine Ahnung.
Komische Smilies.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Du wolltest YouTube weiter scrollen.
Ne, ich wollt noch was sagen.
Zumindest mag ich...
Ah, jetzt vergessen.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier noch?
The day before die Geschichte einer Spiel...
Oh, ne.
Jetzt floss nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Guck mal.
Den kann man sich immer gucken.
Die sind immer angenehm.
Game Streaming ohne Leck.
Also ich hab Moonlight und Sunshine...
...schon vor einer ganzen Zeit.
Vor einer ganzen Weile ausprobiert.
Nummer zwei, was sich auf YouTube triggert?
Wollte ich das sagen?
Ne.
Oder?
Dumme Leute triggern mich immer.
Ne.
Aber ansonsten.
Da gibt's auf YouTube halt genug.
Auf Twitch weniger.
Ich hab das vor einer ganzen Weile mal ausprobiert.
Moonlight, Sunshine.
Beziehungsweise Moonlight fast damals.
Glaub noch.
Moonlight ist ja nur der Client.
Soweit ich das weiß.
Der Client für...
Also.
Im Prinzip ist Moonlight eine Reimplementierung von Nvidia Game Stream.
Wolltest du was über Shorts generell sagen?
Ach. Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt Game Streaming ohne Leck an.
Ich hab das vor einer ganzen Weile ausprobiert.
Da war das wirklich sehr, sehr nice.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist mein PC im Arbeitszimmer und das ist mein Fernseher drei Räume weit.
Kann man mit Moonlight, Sunshine mittlerweile auch gescheit den kompletten Desktop streamen?
Und auf dem Fernseher spiele ich Cyberpunk 2077 in 4K HDR.
Auch Linux auf Windows?
Geht auch ohne spürbare Verzögerung.
Okay, sorry.
Wahrscheinlich alles außer Wayland, oder?
Wieder mal.
Und jetzt kommt an dem Fernseher hängen überhaupt keine Videokabel.
Das Spiel läuft auf meinem PC und wird übers interne Netz direkt auf den TV gestreamt von einer App, die direkt auf dem Fernseher läuft.
Und um es muss auch der Controller nicht mit dem PC gekoppelt sein, sondern einfach nur mit dem Fernseher.
In diesem Video erkläre ich euch, wie dieses Kunststück funktioniert.
Und wenn ihr keinen kompatiblen.
LG-Fernseher habt, könnt ihr das auch einfach über ein Raspi, ein Steam Deck, ein Handy, ein Alpinclient, ein Notebook oder ein Tablet springen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass Nvidia Shield kann es auch, weil da kommt das ja mit unter anderem her.
... Stream anzeigen kann.
Natürlich ist das auch alles Open Source und kostenlos.
Also in meiner App bei Android TV wird es ja schon geben.
... und Sunshine.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Eckerin, liebe Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
... D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D.
... D-D-D-D-D-D-D.
Ja, Streaming vom PC ist praktisch.
VPNs sind ebenfalls praktisch.
Damit lässt sich nämlich Geld sparen.
Ah, NordVPN.
NordVPN.
Und damit kann man sich ganz einfach in beliebige Ländertunnel.
Und wenn man dann auf irgendeine Website geht, denkt die, man ist in eben diesem anderen Land.
Damit kann man zum Beispiel Sachen bestellen, die...
Ja, NordVPN wollte bei mir Werbung machen.
Aber dann haben sie entdeckt, das habe ich euch jetzt schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
...
NordVPN wollte bei mir Werbung machen und wir waren uns auch schon einig, eigentlich
ganz nicer Deal und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, der Max hat bei sich auf dem Kanal ein Video,
das sich nennt Lügen der VPN Anbieter und da geht es gar nicht explizit um NordVPN,
sondern so allgemein um, okay NordVPN ist auf dem Thumbnail, NordVPN ist auf dem Thumbnail
drauf, okay, okay und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, ich habe ein Video und das hat ihnen nicht
gefallen und dann wollten sie nicht mehr und sie haben gesagt, ja wir freuen uns über
die Kooperation und freuen uns bald starten zu können, aber das haben die so nebensächlich
erwähnt, so nach dem Motto, ja, also so nach dem Motto, ja das ist ja ganz toll und
wir freuen uns darüber und wir möchten auch bald starten und das ist alles ganz toll
und wir sind super hyped und wir haben da aber ein Video gefunden, könntest du das
bitte noch entfernen und wann denkst du denn hochzuladen, so nach dem Motto, wann denkst
du denn die Kooperation hochzuladen, das haben die so in nem ganz kleinen Nebensatz erwähnt,
dass die, dass die wollen, dass ich mein Video lösche, ja, so nach dem Motto, ja alles, alles
klar, alles klar.
Alles klar und alles gut, aber lösch doch mal dein Video, wann willst du denn unsere
Kooperation starten, das macht ne Agentur, das war nicht NordVPN, das war nicht NordVPN
direkt und da habe ich halt nur, das starten wir halt gar nicht, ich lösche doch keine
Videos, Alter.
Jetzt, solange die nicht erhältlich sind, andere Filme und Serien zum Beispiel auf Netflix
gucken, man kann, CT 3003, Werbung Ende, ja, ich bin mir echt ziemlich sicher, dass viele
Probleme kennen, ihr habt einen PC in Raum A, aber ihr wollt das Ding in Raum B nutzen,
wo ihr zum Beispiel ein großes Display wie nen Fernseher habt oder ihr wollt halt auf
irgendwas Tragbarem euer PC-Game weiterspielen im Badezimmer.
Also es war nicht genug Kohle, dass ich mein Video gelöscht hätte, ne, da muss mir aber
eh schon einer enorm viel Kohle bezahlen, dass ich alte Videos lösche, sogar Activision
wollte damals, dass ich ein altes Video lösche, dass sie mit mir irgendwie zusammenarbeiten
für irgendwie Call of Duty Zeug vor zig Jahren.
Hab ich auch nicht gemacht.
Ich lösche prinzipiell keine Videos, nur weil es irgendjemandem nicht gefällt und der dann
sagt, dann gibt's halt kein Geld, dann haben sie Pech, dann mach ich halt nix.
Ich bin ja da nicht drauf angewiesen oder so.
Und meistens sind diese Videos ja nicht, weil es mir danach wäre, wäre irgendwas zu flamen,
sondern weil sie Scheiße gebaut haben oder halt wirklich irgendwas kacke ist.
Ne, wisst ihr, was noch geiler wär?
Video auf Privatstellen?
Kooperation machen?
Und wenn die Kooperation rum ist, das Video wieder öffentlich?
Das ist eigentlich mega big brain.
Danach checken die das doch eh nicht.
Das hätte ich eigentlich machen müssen, ja.
Das wär's doch.
NordVPN Geld abgreifen und danach das Video wieder public stellen.
Eigentlich ist das die Idee.
Und selbst wenn, was wollen sie machen?
Also bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so, dass ich in meinem Studio, man könnte auch,
Arbeitszimmer oder Rumpelbude sagen, einen richtig guten PC stehen habe.
Wer diesen Channel hier verfolgt, weiß, hier habe ich ja selbst zusammengebaut, die Kiste.
Ja, aber ich sitze dann den ganzen Tag hier schon und will dann natürlich abends nicht auch noch hier in meiner Freizeit rumhängen,
sondern würde dann halt gerne im Wohnzimmer auf dem Sofa chillen.
Aber das ist halt drei Zimmer weiter und der PC ist sehr schwer.
Aber im Wohnzimmer steht halt auch ein 65 Zoll OLED, der für viele Spiele eh besser geeignet ist,
als mein kleiner 27 Zoll PC Monitor.
So, und deshalb habe ich mich jetzt mal...
Ja, je nachdem, je nachdem, ne.
Also, ich mag ja Spielen an einem nicht allzu großen Monitor.
Wo das wirklich cool ist, wo ich beispielsweise auch schon ausprobiert habe, ist,
die letzten Teile habe ich nicht gespielt, aber ältere Assassin's Creed Spiele,
die kommen richtig zur Geltung oder kamen richtig zur Geltung auf dem großen Display, ja, das stimmt.
Aber die meisten Sachen, die ich spiele, da will ich hier in meinem Arbeitszimmer vorm Rechner sitzen,
vorm PC.
240 Hertz Moni...
Äh, 360 Hertz Monitor, ne, 240 Hertz Monitor.
Ich glaube, abgecrayed auf 360 Hertz hatte ich nie und werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Da hole ich mir lieber ein OLED-Display.
Wo sieht man denn noch einmal unter Windows hier die Lands vs. Zombies?
Alles klar.
Advanced Display Information.
140 Hertz, okay.
140.
240, nicht 140, sondern 240 Hertz.
Das ist halt einfach nice, das hast du auf dem Fernsehen nicht.
Diese Sachen mit Fernseh-240 Hertz ist ja oftmals fake, weil Zwischenbildberechnung, nicht wirklich 240 Hertz.
...Streaming reingefogen.
Ja, das ist...
Also bei Fernsehern ist diese Hertz-Angabe oftmals ultra-fake
und bezieht sich nicht auf die wirkliche Refresh-Rate,
sondern auf die Refresh-Rate inklusive Zwischenbildberechnung.
Oder ist das ein...
Meinen die das ernst, ja?
Asus ROG!
OLED mit 480 Hertz.
Nice, das brauche ich.
Der hat bestimmt auch wieder einen Lüfter drin.
Bei Asus ist es ja mittlerweile normal, dass Monitore...
Okay, normal nicht, aber auch kein...
Sagen wir mal so, bei Asus kommt es durchaus auch mal vor, dass Monitore Lüfter haben.
Und der hat bestimmt auch einen Lüfter.
Wahrscheinlich kostet der Monitor dann aber 4000 Euro oder so.
Hier soll sich jederzeit von 4K UHD-Auflösung mit 240 Hertz
auf Full HD
mit 480 Hertz.
Wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
Es hat ewig gedauert.
Die Frage habe ich dem Asus-Marketing-Mensch gestellt,
auf der ESL One in Köln,
wann es denn sowas geben wird.
Da habe ich mir gedacht,
es dauert noch ein bisschen,
aber dass das bisschen quasi 8 Jahre sind,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Oder irgendwie, na nicht 8 Jahre, 6 Jahre oder so.
Das ist schon mal nice, ja?
Full HD, 480 Hertz.
Das ist natürlich echt nur was für...
...sagen wir mal, super-competitive-Games
in ultra-low-Settings.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher,
ich meine, CS läuft überall,
aber ich bin mir nicht mal sicher,
ob das neue CS überhaupt mit 480 Hertz gescheit läuft, ja.
Wobei doch, wird das machen,
weil die meisten Leute spielen das ja noch nicht mal auf Full HD.
Die spielen das ja auf niedrigsten Settings
in, frag mich nicht,
aber ich glaube,
das ist schon mal ein bisschen
eine unheimliche oldschool-Auflösung.
Und wahrscheinlich rendert das mit 480 Hertz.
Wie groß ist der Monitor?
39 Zoll ist mir persönlich auch zu fett, ja.
Aber man muss halt sagen,
39 Zoll macht schon Sinn bei einem 4K-Monitor.
Aber das ist mir für meinen Schreibtisch zu groß.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt...
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
26 Zoll oder so?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich würde nachgucken,
wenn an meinem Monitor was dranstehen würde.
Hab ich nicht irgendein Bild?
Ja.
Ist das der?
25 Zoll, ja.
Den habe ich aktuell.
Ja, nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich habe nicht diese komischen Seitenteile dran.
So, das Ding.
Das Teil habe ich aktuell.
Seit einer Weile.
240 Hertz.
Das ist nicht das geilste Panel,
aber es ist auch nur ein Full-HD-Monitor.
Der nächste Monitor wird dann ein bisschen,
vielleicht minimal größer,
aber mit mehr Auflösung.
Und dann auch OLED und 240 Hertz.
Oder vielleicht sogar 480,
wenn ich noch ein bisschen warte.
So als Upgrade sehr nice.
Ja, aber cool,
dass es da langsam noch ein paar Innovationen gibt.
Okay, weiter.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein alter Hut.
Arzi, danke schön für den Sub.
Sgt. Silver POG-Subscription
habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Der Wobblos hat einen Sub gegiftet.
Wer hätte das gedacht,
dass der Wobblos so macht?
2017 hat Valve die Steam Link-Hardware ausgebracht.
Die hat genau das gemacht.
Das kleine Kistchen per HDMI,
ein Fernseher,
einen Controller mit dem Kästchen gekoppelt
und dann vom PC übers Netz gestreamt.
Drei Jahre später war es dann aber schon wieder vorbei
mit der Steam Link-Hardware.
Und die Technik ist jetzt einfach in Steam integriert
und heißt jetzt Remote Play.
Aber zumindest bei mir hat das immer nur so halb gut funktioniert.
Also irgendwas hat da früher immer gehakt, geruckelt.
Was jetzt aber nicht heißen soll,
dass das bei euch auch so sein muss.
Also ich möchte Steam Remote Play jetzt auch nicht dissen,
sondern sage nur Moonlight und Sunshine
haben bei mir deutlich besser.
Also bei mir kann ich dir sagen,
mein Monitor ist ungefähr...
Habe ich irgendwas zu messen?
Ich kann es dir sagen,
mein Monitor ist ziemlich genau eine Unterarmlänge entfernt
von meiner Tastatur.
Also ziemlich nah dran.
Mit der Software, also Moonlight und Sunshine,
die ich in diesem Video vorstelle,
habe ich auf meinem Setup wirklich so gut wie keine Probleme gehabt.
Kurzer Einschub, mein Setup
und ich liste das hier jetzt mal so detailliert wie möglich auf,
weil diese Streaming Sachen sehr unterschiedlich
auf unterschiedlichen Systemen laufen.
Da sind dann solche konkreten Angaben ganz praktisch.
Also auf der Host-Seite habe ich einen Windows 11 PC
mit AMD 7950X3D.
Ist leistungstechnisch ungefähr das, was ich auch habe.
Wobei seine CPU für Games ein bisschen,
ein Ticken schneller ist.
CPU und...
Aber auch ein Jahr neuer.
RTX 4090 und auf der kleinen Seite
einen LG OLED 65 CX Fernseher von 2020
mit direkt mit dem TV über Bluetooth gekoppelten
PS5 DualSense Game Controller.
Auf dem Fernseher läuft die LG WebOS App von Moonlight.
Also da ist der Developer Mode erforderlich,
dazu später mehr.
Im Netz hängen alle Geräte per LAN Kabel gekoppelt
über D-Link DGS Switches an einer Fritzbox 66.
Ich habe damit mehrere Stunden
auf meinem Fernseher vom PC gestreamt gespielt
und ganz ehrlich hätte man mir gesagt,
der PC ist direkt per Kabel ans TV eingeschlafen,
hätte ich das auch geglaubt.
Ich habe keine Verzögerung bei der Steuerung festgestellt
und auch keine Bildfehler oder Artefakte gesehen.
Das einzige, hin und wieder stoppte der Ton mal
für eine Viertelsekunde oder so.
Aber da hätte ich zuerst eh gedacht,
dass es halt am Spiel liegt.
Zumal es auch noch Cyberpunk ist.
Das fragt man mir allerdings bei mehreren Spielen auf,
also liegt das wohl ziemlich sicher am Streaming.
Aber wirklich doll gestört hat mich das nicht.
Also insgesamt ist das mit Abstand die beste Qualität,
die ich bislang beim Thema Spielestreaming so gesehen habe.
Und ich habe auch schon sehr intensiv mit anderen Streaminglösungen
wie damals Google Stadia und zum Beispiel Shadow...
...intensiv mit anderen Streaminglösungen
wie damals Google Stadia...
Dazu muss ich jetzt einfach nochmal...
...
... ...
... ... ...
Man findet halt die offizielle Aussage von dem Typ nicht.
Keine Ahnung, aber...
Also Google Stadia hat ja behauptet, bei ihnen gäbe es negativ Latency, weil das so geil ist. Das ist weird. Also was die, die haben ja da ein bisschen zurückgerudert, haben das erklärt und haben gesagt, ja, aber bei Multiplayer-Spielen ist es ja so, dadurch, dass dann quasi nur noch der In- und Output gestreamt wird zum Spieler und die Spiele selbst im gleichen Rechenzentrum laufen, wie dann quasi auch die Clients laufen, dann hat man quasi weniger Latency,
wie wenn alles bei einem daheim laufen würde. Das wollten sie damit sagen. So, man hat dann quasi negativ Latency, was halt echt affig ausgedrückt war. Und wie gut Stadia geklappt hat, sieht man ja.
Also das Programm läuft auf dem Server, also dem Rechner.
Ich wusste von Anfang an, dass Stadia ein Griff ins Klo wird.
... der Bild und Ton berechnet. Moonlight ist der Client, der empfängt den Video- und Audio-Stream von Sunshine und schickt da auch die Controller-Befehle hin.
Ursprünglich war Moonlight ein Hack für Nvidias Game Stream.
Daher kenne ich das auch und da habe ich das auch ausprobiert mit.
Also damit man das auch mit anderen Geräten als mit dem NVIDIA Shield machen kann.
Richtig.
Game Stream ist genau das, was ich gerade erklärt habe, nur eben von NVIDIA, eingebacken in den Grafikkarten.
Und mittlerweile nicht mehr supportet, soweit ich weiß.
Und die wollten halt damals ihre Shield-Hardware verkaufen, denn zuerst hat das nur damit funktioniert.
Also der Gaming-PC brauchte eine NVIDIA-Grafikkarte und als Client konnte man nur so eine NVIDIA-Shield-Box verwenden.
Mit dem Moonlight-Projekt...
Konnte man das Ganze dann auch ohne Shield verwenden.
Also zum Beispiel auf Raspis oder Tablets.
NVIDIA hat aber jetzt künstlich die Entwicklung von Game Stream eingestellt.
Verstehe ich gar nicht.
Das war ein richtig nice Feature.
Also das wird auch nicht weiterentwickelt.
Stand heute ist die Game Stream-Funktion zwar immer noch im NVIDIA-Treiber zu finden,
aber auf NVIDIA Shields wird bzw. wurde die Funktion entfernt.
Aber das ist ja auch alles gar nicht schlimm, denn es gibt ja Sunshine.
Und diese Open Source-Software bildet Game Stream nicht nur nach,
sondern hat auch noch gegenüber Game Stream einige Vorteile.
Vor allem läuft sie nicht nur auf NVIDIA-Grafikkarten, sondern auch auf AMD- oder Intel-Grafik-Hardware.
Und sie läuft auch nicht nur unter Windows, sondern auch unter Linux und macOS.
Während Sunshine anfangs noch nicht ganz so gut funktionierte wie Game Stream,
ist das inzwischen zumindest bei unseren Tests mindestens genauso gut.
Die Installation.
Sunshine ist super leicht zu installieren.
Einfach hier zum Beispiel auf GitHub die für euer System passende Version runterladen.
Also hier unter Windows.
Also diese hier.
Und einfach doppelklicken zum Installieren.
Dann öffnet sich eine Seite im Browser, wo ihr einmal Login-Passwort festlegen müsst.
Eventuell warnt euch euer Browser, dass ihr euch mit einer unsicheren Seite verbindet.
Das müsst ihr dann einmal erlauben.
Wenn ihr eingeloggt seid, könnt ihr Sunshine konfigurieren.
Ich würde euch raten, dass alles erstmal auf den Voreintritt könnt ihr Sunshine...
Das ist ne Bootstrap-Webseite, oder?
Das sieht so ultra-Bootstrap-y aus.
Das Bootstrap, Leute.
...konfigurieren.
Ich würde euch raten, das alles erstmal auf den Voreinstellungen zu lassen.
Tweaken könnt ihr das später immer noch.
Das Einzige, was wichtig ist, hier unter Applications könnt ihr die Spiele oder Programme eintragen,
die ihr dann direkt in Moonlight starten wollt.
Voreingestellt ist bei Sunshine Desktop und Steam.
Also halt einfach euer Desktop, klar, und Steam im Big-Picture-Modus.
Wenn ihr da manuell eine Software reinwerfen wollt, auf Add New klicken,
hier oben bei Application Name den Namen des Spiels reinschreiben
und bei Detached Command.
Dann einfach den kompletten Pfad zur ausführbaren Datei rein.
Um den Pfad easy zu kopieren, einfach Shift und Rechtsklick auf die Echse des Spiels
und dann auf Alt...
Shift plus Rechtsklick.
Moment, überspringt Shift plus Rechtsklick etwa dieses dumme neue Menü?
Ah!
Das kannte ich ja noch gar nicht.
Es gibt jetzt einen Shortcut, um dieses dumme neue Menü zu überspringen.
Wo ich nicht weiß, warum es überhaupt da ist.
Ehrlich gesagt.
What's using this file?
Was bin ich hier am?
Hi, Locksmith.
What?
Ah, ist das Power Toys, die ich hier am Start habe?
Nee.
Ich hab aber Power Toys doch gar nicht an.
Power Toys.
Settings.
Äh, ich mach mal kurz alles aus.
Weil ich eigentlich davon, wenn überhaupt, nur die Keyboard-Shortcuts verwende.
Ja.
Dann einfügen und einmal auf das grüne Plus klicken.
Und ist das jetzt weg, wenn ich's wieder mal anklicke?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Bei Image unten könnt ihr Find Cover klicken und dann...
Oh, das ist ja cool, dass sie das gleich wieder eingebaut haben.
Das geht's dann zu irgendeiner Spiele-Datenbank und lädt sich ein Bild runter dazu.
Dann heißt es automatisch ein passendes Bild.
Save klicken, fertig.
Falls Sunshine direkt beim Systemstart starten soll, geht ihr bei laufendem Sunshine unter Windows in Dienste.
Windows-Taste und dann halt Dienstklicken.
Dienste eingeben und sucht beim Buchstaben S den Sunshine-Service.
Und hier dann unter Eigenschaften Starttyp automatisch auswählen.
Zack.
Weil Windows-Logik.
Starttyp automatisch.
Das ist vor allem dann sinnvoll, wenn ihr über den Moonlight-Client euren PC...
Okay, ganz ehrlich, weil Windows...
Ob ich jetzt Services startautomatisch sage oder Systemctl enable-Service, eigentlich macht's keinen großen Unterschied.
... über Wake Online hochfahren wollt.
Tatsächlich hab ich das...
Das geht jetzt bei mir so laufen und das funktioniert auch einwandfrei.
Weil ich kein Auto-Login in Windows einstellen will, muss ich dann nur über den Moonlight-Client meinen Windows-Pin eingeben.
Ja, das wird bei mir nicht funktionieren.
Das geht aber ganz gut.
Und runterfahren kann man den immer dann zum Beispiel auch ganz komfortabel über Steam Big Picture.
Ja, und dann braucht ihr eben noch Moonlight als Client.
Und das läuft wirklich nahezu überall.
Also auf den üblichen Desktop-Betriebssystemen sowieso, auf Raspis, auf LG-Fernseher, auf Chrome OS, auf der Nintendo Switch.
Es gibt sogar eine...
RISC-V-Version.
Ich zeig euch hier mal vier Installationen.
Hier Nummer eins unter Windows.
Es gibt einen Installer, den kann man einfach doppelklicken oder auch eine portable Version.
Hier entpackt ihr die ZIP-Datei in einen Ordner und startet dann Moonlight.exe.
Dann müsst ihr Client und Host koppeln.
Das passiert, indem ihr die vierstellige Zahl, die Moonlight euch anzeigt, einmal in Sunshine eintippt.
Ist beides einmal gekoppelt, müsst ihr das auch nicht wieder machen.
Ja, und dann könnt ihr hier in den Moonlight-Einstellungen einmal die Auflösung festlegen und dann noch ein paar andere Einstellungen.
Hier würde ich auch allgemein...
Das ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Sparst du dir dann die Spielekonsole?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Weil du Exklusivspiele auch nicht damit spielen kannst.
Du kannst damit nur deine PC-Spiele halt rüber streamen.
Das läuft ja weiterhin auf deinem PC, es wird ja nur die Ausgabe gestreamt und der Input.
Spielekonsole sparst du dir damit nicht.
Wenn du Konsolen-Exklusiv-Sachen spielen willst.
Aber das ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Also ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig an meine Moonlight-Experimente erinnern, aber damals sah das noch nicht so nice aus.
... empfehlen erstmal mit den Standard-Werten zu arbeiten, könnt ihr alles hinterher noch rumfummeln.
Nummer 2, auf Raspis ab Raspi 4 installiert ihr Moonlight mit diesem Befehl hier.
Steht auch unten in der Beschreibung.
Cute Moonlight.
Da könnt ihr Moonlight dann einfach mit Moonlight-QT.
Am besten funktioniert das, wenn ihr parallel keinen Desktop...
Ein richtig cutes Moonlight war das.
Dafür könnt ihr zum Beispiel Raspberry Pi OS Lite installieren, da ist gar kein Desktop enthalten.
Achtet nur darauf, dass ihr möglichst die aktuelle Version nehmt, die auf Debian 12 Bookworm basiert.
Nummer 3, auf LG-Fernsehern mit WebOS als Betriebssystem ist die Installation auch einigermaßen einfach.
Ihr müsst euch allerdings einmal zwingend auf webostv.developer.lgi.com einen Developer-Account anlegen.
Und dann müsst ihr auf eurem Fernseher...
Also hey...
Weil für das Shield TV wird es ja auf jeden Fall funktionieren, hoffe ich mal.
...Mode-App installieren, die findet ihr einfach im normalen LG-Content-Store.
Und dann diese App starten, einloggen mit dem von euch angelegten Login und dann auf Enable Developer Mode drücken und auf den Neustart des Fernsehers warten.
Dann nochmal die Developer-Mode-App starten und Dev-Mode-Status auf On schalten und den Key-Server aktivieren.
Alles klar.
Dann notiert oder merkt oder fotografiert euch die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher hat.
Die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher anzeigt und die Passphrase.
Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Remaining Session 999 Stunden 58...
Das ist einfach die maximale Zeit, die geht, oder was?
Die IP-Adresse, die euer Fernseher anzeigt und die Passphrase.
Ja, und dann könnt ihr an euren Rechner gehen und das Programm WebOS DevManager installieren.
Das starten...
Ach das, natürlich.
Obviusly.
Bei Connection Mode auf Use Developer Mode klicken.
Da dann nochmal die Checkliste angucken, ob ihr alles gemacht habt.
Dann könnt ihr bei Device Name eurem Fernseher einen Namen geben und die IP-Adresse eintippen und die Passphrase.
Ich finde aber gut, dass LG das ermöglicht.
Also, umso mehr man machen kann auf seinem Gerät, umso mehr Freiheit man hat, umso besser finde ich das.
Ich finde das gut, dass die Hersteller das ein bisschen verstecken, dass nicht jeder Kack-Noob das einschalten kann.
Aber ich finde, umso mehr du machen kannst, umso besser.
Ja, zack, seid ihr mit eurem Fernseher verbunden.
Dafür gibt's EasyClap, genau.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht illegal oder so.
Da habt ihr euch nicht gar Belarus gerootet, sondern das ist einfach nur der Developer-Mode.
Das ist so vorgesehen und ...
Sein GerätRooten ist auch so nicht illegal.
... die Moonlight-App installieren.
Wichtiger Hinweis auch noch.
Trotzdem reiß.
Ach! Der Kram läuft wirklich ab!
Schrott, Alter!
Tastatur an den Fernseher anschließen.
Der hat ja USB-Buchsen.
Ihr könnt aber auch unter Einstellungen, Anschluss, Einstellung der Geräteverbindung
einen Bluetooth-Controller koppeln.
Wenn ihr jetzt Moonlight startet, sollte sich schon das Hauptmenü mit dem Controller steuern lassen.
Die Maus bewegt ihr übrigens, wenn ihr nur einen Controller angeschlossen habt,
mit gleichzeitig befugter Mitteltaste.
Das ist mega nice gemacht.
PlayStation-Taste und Analog-Stick rechts.
Installation Nummer 4.
Auf dem Steam Deck installiert ihr Moonshine im Desktop-Modus einfach über Discount.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe 7LQS.
Dass ihr dann halt Moonshine auch im normalen Steam Deck-Menü seht.
Du wirst keine App dafür bauen können, weil Apps keinen Zugriff darauf haben.
Auf dieses Extenden vom Developer-Mode.
100 Pro wird das nicht gehen.
Ich habe eine alte externe Festplatte.
Die wird nicht mehr vom Rechner erkannt und klackt.
Aber hat jemand einen Tipp, wie ich die Festplatte komplett zerstören kann,
wenn ich alles auftraue?
Also, ein grundsätzlicher Tipp ist, immer Vollverschlüsselung nutzen.
Dann hast du prinzipiell keine Probleme und kannst sie einfach wegschmeißen.
So, aber hast du jetzt ja nicht gemacht.
Aber das ist so prinzipiell eines der Gründe, warum ich auf allen meinen Laufwerken Vollverschlüsselung habe.
Wegen genau sowas.
Das zweite ist Festplatten zerstören.
Du kannst es so machen wie Google.
Da brauchst du aber so eine hydraulische Presse für.
Das wirst du nicht haben.
Ansonsten würde ich ehrlich gesagt einfach ein bisschen mit dem Hammer drauf rumhauen.
Oder durchbohren.
Ich würde aber ein bisschen mit dem Hammer drauf rumhauen.
Ganz im Ernst.
Eine Festplatte ist relativ fragil gegen Schläge.
Und wenn es eine alte Magnetfestplatte ist,
hämmer da einfach ein paar mal drauf ordentlich mit richtig Schmackes mit dem Hammer.
Dann ist das Ding kaputt.
Kann man die Vollverschlüsselung nicht nachträglich machen?
Ja nicht, wenn die Festplatte nicht mehr funktioniert.
Du kannst sie nachträglich machen, solange das Gerät noch funktioniert.
Aber das Gerät funktioniert ja nicht mehr.
Ja, du kannst durchbohren.
Du kannst aber einfach draufhauen.
Du kannst einfach draufkloppen.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du es auch aus dem Fenster schmeißen oder so.
Aus dem zweiten Stock.
Ein paar mal.
Aber ich würde lieber mit dem Hammer ein paar mal draufhauen.
Ordentlich, ordentlich Schmackes.
Reicht da BitLocker?
Wenn du dem Hersteller von BitLocker vertraust, ja.
... und Moonlight unterstützen übrigens prinzipiell HDR.
Aber das geht nur, wenn das physisch an den Hostrechner angeschlossene Display auch HDR kann.
Bei mir ist das so, dass man normalerweise im Arbeitszimmer kein HDR bekommt.
Aber der OLED-Fan...
Kann meine HDR?
BenQ...
2...
Fuck.
Habe ich den nicht eben gerade irgendwo gesucht?
BenQ...
Ja.
Der da.
Kann der HDR?
Übersicht.
Nice.
Ist gut, dass die BenQ-Seite so gut funktioniert.
Kann der HDR?
Nein.
Nee.
Brat.
Ah, das ist die Display-Test-Seite.
HDR.
Öh...
Wo ist denn der...
... Datenblatt?
HDR.
Kein HDR.
No!
Sack.
... im Wohnzimmer schon.
Um hier jetzt HDR aktivieren zu...
Das kann man bestimmt faken unter Windows.
... können, bräuchte ich halt entweder einen HDR-fähigen Arbeitsplatzmonitor
oder so einen sogenannten Edit-Emulator.
Ja, genau.
Also ein kleines Kästchen, was dem Rechner einen beliebigen Monitor vorraukelt.
Ich habe so einen für 6,99 ausprobiert und das klappt tatsächlich.
Nice.
Was noch wichtig ist, eigentlich ist das Ganze alles nur zum Streamen im eigenen Heimnetz.
Aber ihr könnt euren PC über Sunshine auch nach außen streambar machen.
Also dass ihr zum Beispiel im Urlaub oder so per Tablet auf eurem PC zockt.
Dafür könnt ihr das im Moonlight...
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
Nimmst dein Notebook oder so mit?
VPN nach Hause und...
Let's go.
Ist ja die Frage, wie gut das Hotel-WLAN ist.
... Link-Tool installieren.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Mein Fazit.
Also, Stink-Tool installieren.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Mein Fazit.
Also, im 3003-Team fanden alle...
Du brauchst dann aber jemanden, der daheim deinen Rechner rebooten kann, gell, wenn was ist.
... im Vorschlag mit dem PC-Game-Streaming ziemlich speziell.
So nach dem Motto, machen das echt Leute?
Aber ich kenne echt eine ganze Menge Menschen, die irgendwo einen Desktop-PC stehen haben, damit gerne spielen würden.
Man muss ja nicht spielen damit.
Man kann ja auch einfach den Desktop dahin...
... streamen, wo einfach ein Display steht oder ein Fernseher.
Also, irgendwo, wo nicht der PC steht.
Und rumtragen von so einem fetten Desktop-PC ist ja auch keine gute Option.
Also, ich kann euch versichern, dass ich das Ganze weiterhin regelmäßig nutzen werde.
Ich habe nämlich zum Beispiel GTA 5 nach Jahrzehnten immer noch nicht durchgespielt, habe aber einen alten PC...
Ich auch nicht.
... und will das jetzt gerne auf dem Sofa zu Ende spielen.
Und ich bin echt sehr pingelig, was die Bildqualität angeht.
Also, wenn das jetzt schlechter aussehen würde als direkt am PC, dann würde ich das nicht machen.
Ich finde, es sieht wirklich gut aus.
Und wenn man dann noch bedenkt, dass Sony mit dem Portal sogar eine eigene Handheld-Konsole rausgebracht hat,
die nur dafür da ist, die Bild- und Tonausgabe einer PS5 zu streamen.
Also, vielleicht ist das Ganze doch ein Thema, was viele Leute interessiert.
Kleine Bonus-Info, mit dem Tool Chiaki könnt ihr die PS5 sehr komfortabel auf Steam Deck streamen.
Ja, jedenfalls, wie seht ihr das ganze Streaming-Thema?
Findet ihr es interessant oder ist das für euch Fricke-Kram, den niemand braucht?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Abonnieren natürlich.
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
Und wenn ich Anwendungszweck dafür hätte, würde ich es auch noch mal ausprobieren.
... erst am Sonntag, weil wir fahren nämlich nach New York, um uns ein komisches Headset zu kaufen.
Tschüss.
Oh, Maurice hat ein neues Diablo 4 Video.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, Diablo 4 juckt mich eigentlich gar nicht mehr großartig.
Beziehungsweise hat mich nie groß gejuckt.
Ich hab's ja gar nicht...
... nicht mal gekauft, ja.
Nach den letzten Blizzard-Enttäuschungen.
Natürlich muss es faster sein,
... weil es in Rust-Rituals...
... dritten ist.
Was sonst?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
The Day Before, die Geschichte einer Spielekatastrophe, die jeder kommen sah.
Ich sah die Spielekatastrophe von The Day Before nicht kommen.
Und wisst ihr auch, warum nicht?
Weil mich das Spiel so null interessiert hat von Anfang an.
Null. Gar nicht.
Ich hab nie den Hype um das Spiel verstanden.
Kann...
Kann mir schlüssig irgendjemand den Hype um dieses Spiel erklären?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ich hab das mitbekommen, dass da alle gehypt drauf sind.
Hab festgestellt, okay, es ist ein Multiplayer-Zombie-Survival-Game.
Als gäbe es nicht schon 5 Milliarden Multiplayer-Zombie-Survival-Games.
Ich hab's nicht...
Keine Ahnung, ich...
Es war mir komplett unbegreiflich.
Gutes Marketing hatten sie vielleicht, so ein bisschen danach, ja.
Aber so der initiale Hype muss ja auch erst mal...
... und das Interesse muss ja auch erst mal da sein.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Vielleicht sollen wir uns das Video angucken.
Kriegen wir das erklärt.
Ah ja.
Übrigens.
Das...
Das Game wurde ja eingestellt mittlerweile.
MonkaS.
Musik, Alter.
Ich auch nicht.
Geht...
Jetzt geht...
Geht's dir genauso wie mir.
Ich hab bis heute keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, doch, ich weiß, was der Unterschied ist.
Äh...
Days Gone ist ein...
Ein Singleplayer.
Also...
Ja...
Action-Dings.
PlayStation.
Ursprünglich PlayStation.
PlayStation exclusive.
Spiel mit Zombie.
Endzeit-Thematik.
Das...
Dates ist ein...
AMA-Mod.
Und...
Dann gab es noch Warts.
Gab es doch zwischenzeitlich auch noch, oder?
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Warts?
Steam?
Das heißt, zwischenzeitlich wurde das umbenannt.
Ach, jetzt...
Jetzt heißt es wieder Warts.
Hieß es nicht die ganze Zeit?
Ja, das ist wieder was anderes.
A1.
Z1 gab es noch.
Es gab noch Survivors.
Survivor-Stories oder sowas.
Infestation.
Genau.
Survivor-Stories gab es da noch.
2020.
Ja.
Da gab es so viel und ich fand alles mega lahmarschig und langweilig.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Back 4 Blood sind die ehemaligen Left 4 Dead-Leute.
Das ist quasi nur Left 4 Dead in schlechter.
Hast du dir schon die neuen Sideloading-Richtlinien angesehen?
Nee.
Was gibt es denn da Neues?
Muss man den Kram jetzt nicht irgendwie laufen? Neues Sideloaden?
Okay, lass uns mal gucken.
Und aus die Maus.
The Day Before ist seit dem 22. Januar 2024 offiziell Geschichte.
Eingestellt.
Publisher Mytona hat alle Server des Vermeidens...
Ich muss ja auch dazu sagen, ich habe von Mytona noch nie was gehört.
... Survival-MMOs rausgeschaut.
Und von Dings hier, von Pantastic auch nicht.
Ich lecke Critical Information, ja.
Wieso, ist das mittlerweile wieder da, oder wie?
Browser Engines außer Webkit sind jetzt erlaubt.
Heißt das wirklich, wir sehen jetzt einen echten Chrome unter iOS?
Ja, aber Moment, Moment.
Da ist doch garantiert wieder irgendwelche Beschränkungen drinne.
So nach dem Motto, Chrome Browser Engine...
Oder Chrome darf keine PWA's auf den Startbildschirm installieren und sowas.
Da gibt es doch garantiert irgendwelche.
Das lese ich mir jetzt nicht alles durch.
Da gibt es doch 100 Pro wieder irgendwas.
Bevor sie zu YouTube weiter geht, ich lehne einfach alles ab.
Okay, dann gucken wir das mal.
Wo ist der hier?
Was ist der Teil davon, den ich mir angucken muss?
Das Intro, oder?
Ach hier, iOS Changes.
Und heute war der zweite für mich.
Apple hat endlich die Frage beantwortet,
wie die Komplizierung mit den Regeln des EU-Digitalen Markets Act aussehen wird.
Und die Antwort ist...
Malicious.
Ich habe gehofft, es wäre lecker, aber wir...
Schnell.
Ich meine, es klingt gut zu Beginn.
Apple hat beantragt, dass iOS dritte-Partei App-Store unterstützt.
Sie nennen sie Marketplaces.
Sogar dritte-Partei Payment-Systeme und Browser Engines außer Webkit,
damit man tatsächlich einen Browser benutzen kann,
wie bei Safari mit Chrom-Spray-Paint.
Aber dann erkennt man, dass diese leckeren Tricks nur zur EU kommen,
weil sie wirklich sehr gefährlich sind und...
Also sprich, im Endeffekt...
macht Apple das Mindeste, um die EU zufriedenzustellen.
Und nicht generell.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, dass es ziemlich kacke sein wird,
wenn du ein App-Anbieter bist und deine App international vermarkten möchtest.
Ja, deine App quasi das nutzen zu lassen,
weil du es ja nur für Länder in der EU...
Das ist ja schon wieder echt richtig hängen geblieben, oder?
And you're not sure you want them anymore anyways
because you think you saw Apple spit on them before handing them out.
Alternative App Marketplaces must be authorized by Apple
and all the apps that they host must be notarized.
A perfectly dystopian...
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist jetzt ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt...
dass jegliche anderen App-Stores...
direkt gleich wieder unsinnig machen.
Appleism for reviewed by bots and humans.
Prepare to be notarized.
While many are repeating claims that iOS will support sideloading,
installing standalone app packages outside of any app...
Ja, das soll mir recht sein,
dass man den Kram nicht alle Woche oder so neu installieren muss.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Da kann ich vielleicht irgendwann auch mal eine iOS-App bauen,
um mir das mal einfach so just for fun anzugucken,
ohne dass ich einen Apple-Account brauche, Geld bezahlen muss dafür
und ein Code-Signing-Zertifikat brauche.
App Store, like you can do on Android, Windows, Linux and Mac OS,
it won't support that.
And it only gets wilder.
In order for developers to distribute their apps
on alternative app marketplaces
or even use third-party payment processes,
they need to accept the new business terms.
This is the new business now.
Get used to it.
Boah, der Kerl regt mich auf, ey.
That includes paying a lower 10% cut of the App Store revenue,
or 17% for digital goods and services,
plus an extra 3% to use Apples own payment system,
which will also spare users from extra 3%...
Moment.
Musst du jetzt bezahlen, wenn du sideloadest?
Nee, oder?
Moment.
Die bezahlen jetzt weniger?
Für Apps in der EU?
Was ist das?
...to use Apples own payment system,
which will also spare users
from the pop-up warning them
that they may be about to hand over their savings
to a Nigerian prince,
if they don't use the right one.
But the new terms also include Apples own version
of Unity's scandalous per install fee from last year.
Once an app hits one million installs,
its devs will have to pay a core technology fee,
or CTF,
of 50 Euro cents
for every new user who installs it annually.
As in...
Moment, Moment.
Die haben die App schon gekauft,
und die installieren sie dann nochmal,
und dann musst du Geld bezahlen?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Das heißt, du hast eine App,
also das heißt im Endeffekt,
du bringst eine App raus,
für 2 Euro.
Jemand kauft die,
und die App ist super beliebt,
und ganz viele Leute downloaden das,
und irgendwann kauft er sich ein neues iPhone,
lädt sich das neu runter,
dann musst du 50 Cent bezahlen,
wenn er die zum ersten Mal...
Das heißt, im Endeffekt,
da darf sich die 4 Jahre lang installieren, die App,
und du hast kein Geld damit verdient, oder wie?
Und wie ist das, also keine Ahnung,
und wie ist das mit kostenlosen Apps,
kostenlose, sehr beliebte Apps?
Kosten die jetzt Geld, oder was?
Ich weiß, der Entwickler,
das meine ich doch,
wenn du der Entwickler wärst.
Angenommen, du entwickelst eine kostenlose App,
die super beliebt ist,
und du hast auch noch irgendeine QR-Code-Scan-App,
oder sowas, irgendwas, was ganz viele Leute brauchen,
die ist ganz toll, und die geht voll steil,
und dann musst du Geld bezahlen,
für eine kostenlose App.
What? Das ist der Unity-Engine-Move.
Ja, schon.
... für jeden neuen Anwender,
der es jährlich installiert.
Das heißt, die App kann von dem selben Anwender
für 12 Monate nicht bezahlt werden.
Für einige Devs könnte Apple
so etwas wie einen 60-prozentigen Ausgleich
von ihrem App-Rechte sehen.
If you think crossing your fingers
and hoping that your App doesn't get too popular
sounds kind of stressful,
vielleicht sollte ich mir noch ein paar Apple-Aktien kaufen.
Developers can always stick with the current business terms
and swear off the cool new stuff.
They could also target iPadOS,
where first installs
won't trigger the CTF, apparently.
Developers of App-Marketplaces,
however, will have to pay the CTF
every time the Marketplace-App
is installed, including
the first million.
Ja, dann lohnt es sich aber überhaupt nicht,
über extra App-Stores
das Ganze
runterzuladen.
They'll also have to get a letter of credit
Ich sehe schon, das gibt noch längere
Rechtsstreitigkeiten da mit Apple.
... from an A-rated financial institution
of a million euros.
Altogether, the deal doesn't sound too good.
And in their explainers,
Apple is making it clear
that's by design.
The company explained that it's only making
the new features available in the EU
because they're actually super dangerous.
Ja, natürlich.
They can take that.
We're soft and vulnerable.
I mean, the App-Store's harsh protections blocked
two billion dollars worth of fraudulent
transactions in 2022,
the same amount that Google blocked
in the same year
on the far less restrictive Play Store.
But there's way more Android phones
in the world, and they're way harder
to use for babies.
The argument's confusing.
But Apple did announce
that they're going to
have a new app.
One thing that appears to be
just straight up good news,
game streaming platforms like Nvidia's
GeForce Now and Xbox Cloud Gaming
can now submit a single iOS app
with the capability to stream
their entire library of games.
Which is, again, how things already worked
on other operating systems,
but not on the minimalist Fisher-Price
of phones.
Okay, sind wir durch.
Was kommt am Ende?
Das hat mich jetzt eher verwirrt.
Eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock,
das Day-Before-Video zu gucken.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so zur Auswahl?
Was ist das? Major Exploit.
Shitlab. Shitlab.
Was hackt, Leute?
Was hackt?
Was hackt with an image?
Major Exploit.
Wie?
Das ist was Neues?
Nee, oder?
Das ist doch schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ich hab doch die ersten,
nee, das war, genau,
ich hab doch vorhin die ersten paar,
erste Minute schon geguckt.
War 2001 oder so.
Oder 2021.
2001 gab's noch nicht.
Hast du schon deinen neuen Traumjob gesehen?
Nee?
Remote Windows 3.11 Administrator.
Das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
Das ist doch ein Joke.
Am Ende kommt dann...
Ach, she baited.
Wir suchen noch jemand anderen.
Ich safe mir das mal, falls wir's brauchen.
Remote Windows 3.11 Administrator.
Wenn ich weiß Deutsch.
Bei der Gulb Agent.
Das sind doch irgendwelche Personalvermittler, oder?
Das Ergebnis ihrer Arbeit
ist eine hochwertige Displaysoftware,
deren Schnittstellen zur Fahrzeugsteuerung,
ach, uraltes Legacy Zeug,
deren Schnittstellen zur Fahrzeugsteuerung
beziehungsweise Fahrzeugleittechnik,
Reibungsungsfunktionen
auf den,
Fahrzeugleittechnik, Reibungsungsfunktionen auf den
Führerstand, Display, System,
der Hochgeschwindigkeits- und Regionalzüge,
während dem Fahrer die wichtigsten Techniken hat.
Windows 3.11.
No more lost pancakes, sage ich für den Sub.
Was für wirklich Sinn ergibt das jetzt?
Projektbeschreibung,
Treiberaktualisierung, Pflege des Altsystems.
Wie sieht eine Pflege von Windows 3.11 aus?
Dafür gibt's doch nichts Neues mehr.
Skills.
Kenntnisse in Windows 3.11.
Ich kenne Windows 3.11, das war's dann aber auch.
Kenntnisse zu Legacy-Betriebssystemen
und zu Windows-Managern.
Zu Windows-Managern?
Insbesondere MS-DOS
und Windows-Verweigerung.
Was sind zu Windows-Managern?
Was soll das sein?
Window-Manager im Linux-Kontext
kenne ich.
Gerne auch CBUS-Kenntnisse.
Was ist CBUS?
Das Fahr...
Ah, was von der Bahn!
Moment, die Monitore bei der Bahn
laufen noch mit Windows 3.11.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ist das so?
Kenntnisse mit bildgebenden Systemen
oder im Bahnbereich sind von Vorteil.
Kenntnisse zu Legacy-Betriebssystemen
und zu... das hatten wir doch da oben schon mal.
Das bieten wir.
Zahlungszielverkürzung.
Attraktive Möglichkeiten
zur Verkürzung
ihres persönlichen Zahlungsziels.
Was soll mir das sagen?
Dass ich mein Gehalt
schon am 15. anstatt am 20. kriege, oder was?
Hä?
Was ist das? Hä?
Mir ist das doch scheißegal,
ob die am 15. oder am 20. bezahlen.
Die sollen regelmäßig einmal im Monat
die Kohle überweisen.
Die können auch dreimal im Monat überweisen.
Das ist mir auch wurscht.
Den Vorteil hier...
Mir ist das vollkommen egal, wann die das überweisen.
Es sei denn, die überweisen das einmal im Monat.
Einfaches Gutschriftenverfahren.
Kein Zeitraum und Rechnungserstellung mehr nötig.
Hä?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was soll mir das überhaupt sagen?
Einfaches Gutschriftenverfahren.
Keine Zeitraum und Rechnungserstellung mehr nötig.
Was soll mir das sagen?
Ich soll mich um Windows 3.11 kümmern.
Die meinen, dass ich...
Stellen die mich quasi als freier Mitarbeiter an.
Ach so!
Ja, dann ergibt das auch Sinn.
Die stellen mich quasi als freier Mitarbeiter an.
Ach so!
Ja, dann ergibt das auch Sinn.
Die stellen einen quasi als freier Mitarbeiter an.
Ach ja!
Dann...
Jetzt verstehe ich das auch.
Das ist eine Stelle für Freelancer.
Dann ergibt das Sinn.
So nach dem Motto, du bekommst dein Geld einfach früher.
Jetzt ergibt das insgesamt mehr Sinn.
Wenn man das unter dem Gesichtspunkt sieht.
Abrechnung ohne Umwege.
Schnell und zufällig Honorarzahlungen.
Und digitalisierter Unterschriftprozess.
Richtig geile Vorteile.
Massive.
Tja.
Auf Gulb können sie vertrauen.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Ob das stimmt?
Kununu? Gulb?
Naja!
Moment, sind die das überhaupt?
Sind das überhaupt?
Moment, das ist der falsche Laden.
Das ist das Richtige.
Ja, ist schon...
Ganz ehrlich, Gulb-Bewertungen... äh, nicht Gulb...
Gulb-Bewertungen sind in der Regel eh nicht sonderlich gut.
Das ist, das ist glaube ich schon...
in Ordnung.
Mehr Schein als ein.
Ja gut, das ist bei den ganzen Vermittlungsläden so.
Heißt das im Endeffekt,
die suchen eigentlich jemanden für die Bahn?
Du wirst freier
Mitarbeiter bei Gulb und Gulb
vermittelt dich dann an die Bahn.
Und kriegen dafür Fettstocks.
Die könnten auch die Bahn direkt einstellen.
Und dann könnten die sich die ganze
Profession sparen.
Gut.
Sehr, sehr Legacy-lastig.
Aber was ist das für eine...
feinesjobs.online
Klingt ja schon mal, klingt ja schon mal ganz toll.
Was gibt's?
Feinesjobs, feinesjobs.box
wäre jetzt angesagt. Was ist das hier?
Snoggard?
Wer? Wer ist Snoggard?
Klingt irgendwie nach, nach was Schwedischem.
Okay.
Moderner und sicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Du erhältst... Ja, was suchen die denn überhaupt?
Äh, Moment.
Was suchen die denn?
Es ist ja schön, dass ich was erhalte, aber...
Was suchen die denn? So, jetzt
bewerben. Ah, hier.
Filialmitarbeiter. Alles klar.
Das sieht eher nach einer Comedy-
Gruppenseite aus, oder? Also, ich hab
keine Ahnung, was die eigentlich suchen anhand dieser
Webseite. Ja, Filialmitarbeiter
steht in der Adressleiste.
Ja, mal seriously.
Also, es kann jetzt ja nicht sein, dass die Beschreibung
der Stelle in einer, in der Adressleiste
versteckt ist, oder? Da müsste
schon was stehen, was die eigentlich suchen.
Ne, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn für mich
gerade. Das ist der Noob-Filter
wahrscheinlich. Lies den
Firmentitel mal rückwärts.
Trag... Go...
Dragons! Ha!
Okay, das find ich cool.
Das find ich nice.
Snooker, Dragon...
Das find ich nice. Äh, trotzdem
versteh ich nicht, was die eigentlich suchen.
Interessant. Wen sucht ihr denn genau?
Okay, also,
was... Moderner und sicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Ja, erhalte
ein cooles Umfeld mit modernster Technologie.
Hier kannst du nicht nur produktiv arbeiten, sondern
auch spannende Aufgaben übernehmen.
Okay, solange ich kein
Windows-PC benutzen muss. Preisnachlässe
auf unser Angebot, leistungsorientierte Vergütung.
Du erhältst
ein Festgehalt von bis zu...
Das ist ja fast unter Mindestlohn, oder?
Äh, sowie zusätzliche
monatliche Prämien und Provisionen.
Bis zu
30.000 Euro. Nice.
Excellent. Pro Monat?
Okay, dann kann ich von... Dann lass ich mit mir
reden, wenn das pro Monat ist.
Begeisterte Arbeit.
Verwirkliche deine Leidenschaft.
Zusätzliche
Benefits. Okay, interessant. Wen sucht ihr denn genau?
Filial-Mitarbeiter.
Nicht wirklich.
Telesales. Oh Gott, hör mir
bloß auf, Alter. PC-Techniker.
Ja. Pro Monat?
Pro Monat bau ich da auch PCs zusammen.
Kein Ding. Bin ich dabei.
Hehehe.
Nee, die musst du dann bezahlen.
Du musst dann 50 Cent
für jede angefangene Minute
bezahlen an deinen Arbeitgeber, dass du dort arbeiten darfst.
Das ist ja die Apple-Logik.
Jaja, seh ich auch so.
Würde ich auch bauen. Baue ich den ganzen Tag
PCs. Wobei, wenn ich
PCs baue, kriegen die Mainboards immer
Mikro-Risse, wisst ihr ja.
Habt ihr ja gesehen. So.
Eigentlich wollte ich das Video über den GitHub...
Äh, GitLab
Exploit gucken.
Okay, auf geht's.
On April 7th, 2021
Gucken, ob das was taugt.
William Bowling was able to achieve remote code
execution on GitLab.
Oh, das klingt ja super langweilig, Alter.
...which entails...
Oh, nee, nee, nee. Das ist mir zu... Das ist ein...
Das klingt nach Einschlafen des Videos. Kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
GitLab Exploits sind langweilig
mittlerweile. Meinst du, weil es nicht so oft welche gibt?
Kollege... Jetzt würde ich hier Wirecard
lesen. Kollege auf der Arbeit hat gesagt, er hat noch
Wirecard-Aktien. Die behält er
auch. Aus historischen Gründen.
Was ist das denn?
Karrierestart als Ingenieur
bei Südzucker.
So viel hat er noch nie
verdient.
Ja gut, wenn das sein erster Job ist.
Ist klar, dass er noch nie so viel verdient
hat, oder?
Celso von Tarkov. Ich bin wahrscheinlich
der einzige auf der Welt, der das noch nie gespielt hat.
Hast du Aktien?
Ja, habe ich. Guter Hinweis.
Muss mal kurz reingucken.
Stonks.
Was machen die Stonks?
Scalable.
Die Stonks
sagen...
Wow!
Alter!
Die
Stonks gingen ab?
Boah, ey!
Die Stonks gingen ja richtig
ab.
Plus 1001 Euro
in einer Woche.
Massive Stonks, Alter.
Okay, ich meine, davon
habe ich nichts.
Davon habe ich erst was, wenn ich es
verkaufen würde.
Alter, Big Stonks
gingen ja richtig
ab. Pog.
Was macht der Bitcoin-Kurs?
Der ist letztens schon hochgegangen, habe ich schon gesehen.
Wow!
Ja, Bitcoin, genau, wenn ich
das ganz gut habe.
Ich habe nur den ETF.
Das langweiligste, was es gibt, habe ich als ETF.
So, dann gucken wir uns noch das hier
mal an.
Ein Blick in dieses Ingenieurwesen.
Der Drive, den ich habe, der ist bestimmt
auch, weil ich von Haupt- und Mittelschule zu
Abitur und dann zu Bachelor, zu Master, alles
mitgemacht habe. Ich habe noch keinen Plan,
was ich mit so viel Geld mache.
Am besten nicht alles sinnlos
ausgeben, sonst
Not Stonks.
Hallo, ich bin Sui,
32 Jahre alt. Ich bin Training
bei der Südzucker. Ihr werdet also sehen,
wie man hier zum Ingenieur wird.
Okay.
Also ich fahre immer mit dem Board mit
der Arbeit. Während meiner Masterarbeit
begonnen, da konnte ich mir noch kein
Fahrrad leisten.
Und jetzt erst mal auf die Fresse fliegen,
weil Hände in der Tasche und dann nicht
abfangen können.
Ich sehe teilweise Leute mit dem Fahrrad
fahren im Winter, wenn es kalt ist
und die haben die Hände einstecken.
Also das wäre mir nichts.
Ich meine, ich könnte, ich kann nicht
freihändig Fahrrad fahren.
Ich habe teilweise schon Probleme mit
dem Fahrrad. Ich habe teilweise schon
Probleme, wenn ich normal auf dem Fahrrad
sitze und mich umdrehen muss weit,
dass ich rumwackele.
Wie geht das dem Rose-Fahrrad?
Ja, total schade.
Und in meiner Größe ist gerade nichts
lieferbar.
Momentan ist hier
in der Zuckerfabrik viel los.
Da ist Rübenkampagne.
Das heißt, die Rüben werden jetzt geerntet.
Die werden jetzt aus dem Boden gezogen und
kleingegackt und verarbeitet.
Der Ort hier, den, da gucken wir uns
dann später den Zucker an.
Da war ich selbst noch nicht. Das ist dann
der Expeditionsspot für heute.
Der Trainee Technik bei Südzucker
geht insgesamt 18 Monate und alle vier
Monate wechseln wir den Standort.
Der Schwerpunkt der Aufgabe liegt schon im
großen Bereich, im Ingenieursbereich,
im Managementbereich.
Management.
Offiziell arbeite ich glaube ich
7,4 Stunden
pro Tag.
Aber die Arbeit macht mir ziemlich viel Spaß.
Also ich muss mich bemühen, dass ich nicht
über die 10 Stunden komme.
Hallo.
Richtiger High Performer.
Alle Ingenieure ihre
Büros haben.
Das ist mein Büro.
Ich habe zwei Aufgaben hier im Zuckerwerk.
Einmal geht es darum, dass ich
während der Rübenkampagne
die Zuckerfabrik kennenlerne
und erkunde. Dann habe ich auch eine zweite Aufgabe.
Und da geht es um diesen
Reinigungsapparat, den ich planen muss,
den ich entwerfen muss. Damit reinigen sie
verschiedene andere Geräte, die ich hier
während der Produktion
entwerfen muss.
Sind das Handschuhe?
Oder sind das Rührer?
Aufschneidmesser. PDF.
Handschuhe.
Ah, das wird dann hinzugepackt. Da kann man
da so reingreifen.
Reinigen sie verschiedene andere Geräte,
die hier während der Produktion
schmutzig werden. Die haben jetzt ein Gerät,
aber das ist schon ziemlich alt und
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so sicher.
Von einer anderen Zeit sozusagen. Und ich versuche das Ding
eben neu zu machen.
Ich bin aufgeregt. Heute
ein paar wichtige Meetings
für das Projekt.
Ich muss sagen, für
er versprüht
enorm viel positive
Energie, was man so ausdrücken kann.
Sehr viel gesehen. Da habe ich noch richtig viel geguckt.
Ich habe mir gestern zum Beispiel die Abwasseranlage
angeguckt. Das ist so typisch, dass
das, was man bei der Umweltverfahrenstechnik
lernt, da geradeaus. Und dort wird
der Zucker gelagert. Und den schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Ah, das ist ein Killer.
Hallo.
Mein Name ist Sü. Ich bin der neue
Trainer in die Technik. Kann man das angucken?
Boah, ist eine Menge Zucker hier.
Ja, wenn wir hier
die Hallen...
Oh mein...
Jetzt sind sie noch relativ leer.
Wenn wir diese Hallen komplett füllen,
stehen wir ungefähr 4500 Tonnen.
Ich habe ja ziemlich niedrig begonnen.
In der Mittelschule, da hat es schon
viel Arbeit gebraucht, um da rauszukommen,
weil meine Eltern sind mit Migrationshintergrund
nicht dazu fähig, mir bildungstechnisch
so viel... Was Bachelor?
Bachelor Biotechnologie?
Master
Biomasse-Technologie?
Ich wusste noch nicht
mal, dass Biomasse-Technologie
das Wort
überhaupt gibt.
Was ist
Mittelschule? Ja, Realschule.
Ich hatte so viel Support zu geben, dass ich gut durch
diese Zeit gekommen bin. Also
musste alles von alleine passieren.
Ist es nicht Hauptschule?
Ist es nicht Realschule?
Bin ich jetzt sozusagen hier, um
meiner jüngeren Verwandtschaft zu zeigen, okay,
das kann man auch machen.
Danke dir für deine Zeit, Tobi.
Am Ende
konnte er mir noch mit dem
Ausbauprojekt ein paar Informationen geben.
Also Ausbauprojekt ist ja diese Maschine,
die ich da baue.
Okay, dann ist es anscheinend Hauptschule.
Das herausforderndste ist,
dass per Studium einen gar nicht auf...
Aber da sieht man es ja wieder, Schule hat da wenig zu sagen.
... diese Arbeit vorbereitet und man hier sozusagen
rein aus Eigeninitiative
schauen muss, okay, wo kriege ich die
Informationen her, wer kann mir da helfen?
Und da muss man sich
schon manchmal überwinden, Leute anzusprechen.
Herr Kuli, haben Sie gerade... Spricht jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt für die Struktur,
oder?
Wenn du keine Ahnung hast, wo du irgendwo Infos herbekommst?
Hat Zeit.
Jetzt den Auskochkasten
so gut wie fertig geplant.
Ich weiß, wie groß die Pumpe aussehen soll.
Ich weiß, wie groß das Gerät aussehen soll,
wo die Rohrleitungen entlaufen sind.
Und jetzt... Alter!
Da würde ich ja Angst kriegen bei dem Augenkontakt.
Guck mal, der klotzt ihn die ganze Zeit an,
als ist er stinkig mit ihm.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Jetzt den Auskochkasten.
Der guckt ihn sich die ganze Zeit an, so...
Starren, starren, starren, starren, starren.
So gut wie...
Alter, da würde ich ja nervös werden.
Und jetzt geht es mir darum,
wie sieht der Boden aus?
Was für ein Gehäuse mache ich drum rum?
Was für ein Dach habe ich? Habe ich eine Lüftung?
Und all die Sachen.
Die gleiche Idee von Herrn Freitag ist,
ob diese Chemikalie nur im Container bleibt
und nicht überall hier und da.
Er hat mir wieder Tipps gegeben.
Vielleicht ist er auch einfach zu motiviert.
Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich echt
für manche Leute ein Problem.
Wenn die nämlich überhaupt keinen Bock haben
und super motivierte Leute zu ihnen kommen,
dann würde ich das machen.
Es gibt schon eine Anlage, die so ähnlich abläuft.
Er versprüht aber auch enorm viel Motivations...
Ja, Energie so.
Und die würde ich...
Ich weiß, wer sie jetzt designt hat.
Gucke ich mir die Anlage einfach so an.
Ich weiß, wo sie rumsteht.
Die Hoffnung ist, dass ich dann genau das gleiche Ding einfach...
Das ist so jemand, könnte ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Du willst abends heimgehen
und er kommt dann in die Ecke.
Ah, hast du auch mal kurz fünf Minuten Zeit?
Mich würde interessieren, was die zweite Schraube
genau macht.
Aber ist doch nice.
Ich finde es gut, wenn Leute motiviert sind.
Nur sein Teil einfach abkopieren kann
und dann mein Innenleben sozusagen reinhauen kann.
Ich habe genug
unmotivierte Leute gesehen.
Und ich bin auch nicht immer der Motivierteste, ja.
Auch noch dazu.
Lüftung, Pumpe.
So, meine Reaktion,
als ich das gesehen habe.
Das...
Genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht, als ich da reingeguckt habe.
Hier.
Grobe Arbeit.
Ich habe nichts erkannt.
Aber es scheint alles wirklich ordentlich zu sein.
Lüftung, Pumpe, Licht.
Hätte ich auch so gemacht.
Der Boden hat überall solche Auffangwanden.
Das brauche ich auch dann später.
Oder man hätte auch sagen können...
Gibt es das Video noch?
Till it's cool.
Nein, das meine ich gar nicht.
Nice.
Die ganze Arbeit, die ich hier mache,
ist die Vorarbeit für einen Ingenieur.
Das geht an meinen Tutor.
Mit allen möglichen technischen Spezifikationen
und Angeboten, die ich von den Unternehmen habe.
Der ist echt richtig krass motiviert.
Genauso wie die eine von Amazon,
die wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Die war auch komplett gehypt da drauf.
Sodass er, wenn ich dann hier weg bin
und in der nächsten Station bin,
dann kann er einfach die Datei öffnen, schauen, was ich gemacht habe
und dann gleich daraufhin weiterarbeiten.
Realistisch betrachtet bleiben solche Projekte
einfach genau in dem Status
für immer.
Also wenn er weg ist,
wird das einfach liegen bleiben
und niemanden mehr interessieren.
Das habe ich oft genug erlebt bei so Übungsprojekten.
Eigentlich, das wird immer gesagt,
oh ja, das ist schon wichtig
und im Prinzip will es keiner haben.
Ich bin richtig stolz,
da überhaupt die Trainingstelle genommen zu haben,
weil ich habe mich entgegen von Promotionsstellen entschieden.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich
beim alten Arbeitgeber öfters erlebt.
Da hatten wir auch so ein,
also nicht Ausbildungsprogramm,
sondern so ein...
Ich kann euch den Namen jetzt nicht sagen,
aber da konnte man sich bewerben dafür,
wenn du fertig studiert hast.
So ein Ausbildungsprogramm,
also nicht für IHK-Azubis,
sondern sowas, wie VR macht.
Da gab es auch ganz viele Projekte,
so nach dem Motto, oh cool, bräuchten wir.
Und das haben die sich dann angeguckt
und mir fällt jetzt spontan nicht ein Projekt ein,
von was da hinterlassen wurde,
was dann irgendwie weiterverfolgt wurde.
Und da bereue ich es jetzt immer noch nicht.
Quality is destiny!
Oh nein!
Hör mal auf!
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen!
Jetzt hast du mich daran erinnert!
Quality is destiny!
Auch eine große Portion
Jägerschnitzel nehmen, bitte.
Ich auch, würde ich auch.
Große Portion Jägerschnitzel wünsche ich jetzt auch.
Wobei, gleich ist Spaghetti angesagt.
Mein Vater als auch meine Mutter
sind beide von jeher selbstständig gewesen.
Jeder hatte ein eigenes Restaurant.
Von Kind auf musste man
natürlich immer im Restaurant
ausgeholfen werden.
Das war auch kein Problem für mich.
Ich habe das auch durch das gesamte Studium...
Ja, besser als Hartz IV chillen, ne?
Du bist...
Oder, man nennt es ja nicht mal Hartz IV,
es ist jetzt ja Bürgergeld.
...den gesamten Studium alles sozusagen finanziert.
Jetzt nicht, dass ich ein Good Life hatte,
aber genügend, dass ich überleben konnte sozusagen.
Und jetzt ist es soweit,
jetzt habe ich endlich mal den ersten Job,
der erste Lohn kam auch schon rein,
jetzt soweit, dass ich auch was zurückgeben kann.
Jetzt mache ich auch ein bisschen Büroarbeit.
Ich glaube, das macht er auch.
Um zu gucken, wie viele
Rohstoffe brauche ich und wie viele
Reinigungschemikalien brauche ich,
wie viel Wasser brauche ich da.
Ich glaube, er ist wirklich happy über die Chance,
die Renner jetzt hat. Also...
Bei der Amazon-Mitarbeiterin hatte ich
ein bisschen den Eindruck, ja, das ist ein bisschen...
Vielleicht auch ein bisschen
Fake mit dabei, aber dem kaufe ich das
voll ab.
Christian, hast du kurz Zeit?
Christian hat sich gedacht, oh nein,
da ist er schon wieder.
Aber musste durch.
Okay, weiter.
Was denkst du da?
Erstmal kein Gebäude planen.
Christian, hast du kurz Zeit?
Was denkst du da?
Erstmal kein Gebäude planen.
Ich würde eher dahin gehen, dass du noch
Stahlbau planst.
Ich habe dir eine Bushaltestelle vorgestellt,
aber aus Edelstahl dran und dann Trapez.
Danke sehr.
Obviously Trapez, hätte ich auch so gemacht.
Danke. Tschüss.
Feuer auf.
18 Uhr, Mann!
Da bin ich schon
zwei Stunden am MMO... Naja, nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz.
Sagen wir mal so 15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr bin ich weg.
Dann gehe ich hier mal eine Stunde
laufen.
Eineinhalb Stunden, je nachdem und
sagen wir mal so, 18 Uhr
habe ich schon mich bewegt und
eine halbe Stunde MMO gecrindet oder Video
gemacht oder gestreamt oder so, aber...
Also 18 Uhr ist schon hart, ey.
Meine Augen sind echt
müde, aber
viel erreicht. Der ist so happy.
Oh ja, um 18 Uhr noch.
Viele Leute wieder angesprochen.
Brutto verdiene ich monatlich
4.332 Euro.
Ich kriege dann noch eine Überstundenpauschale von
298 Euro und das sind dann
ein Nettogehalt von 2.908 Euro.
Es kommt nach einer Gewinnpartei
etwa 5.000 Euro zusammen.
Also für Training geht das voll klar, oder?
Weihnachtsgeld ist
ein ganzer 13er Monatslohn, also nochmal
4.332 Euro.
Also ausgerechnet, du kommst auf ungefähr
65.000 Euro Jahresgeld.
Also als Trainings...
Ja, man kann ja nicht wirklich Azubi sagen,
aber als Trainee-Gehalt ist das doch
okay. Finde ich gut.
Brutto 65? Das ist ja übel viel.
Ich habe noch keinen Plan, was ich mit so viel Geld
machen kann, bis hierhin sozusagen.
Wisst ihr,
ich fühle mich
bei einer Sache
mit ihm glaube ich
recht, wie soll ich sagen,
recht verbunden und zwar
ich meine, ich kenne ihn nicht, aber
ich habe den Eindruck,
der hat einen
sehr, also ich glaube, wir haben einen ähnlichen
Lebensstil, was die
wie soll ich sagen,
der Bedarf an teuren
Sachen angeht.
Also ich gehe auch davon aus,
der wird genau gucken, was er sich
kauft und
der kommt auch mit wenig aus.
Ja?
Also ich glaube, da sind
wir uns in dem Bereich, zumindest würde ich sagen,
sind wir uns da recht, ich glaube, wir kommen beide
mit wenig aus.
Und bei mir ist es ja nun wirklich auch nicht so,
als müsste ich irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen,
weil ich zu wenig Kohle verdiene.
Ich gebe aber nichts aus.
Ich kaufe mir alle paar Jahre mal einen neuen ordentlichen PC
oder sowas, ja und letztens habe ich, ja okay,
ich habe mir jetzt nach 20 Jahren auch mal wieder
ein Auto gekauft, aber ansonsten,
das letzte Jahr war halt insgesamt relativ
viel, wo ich Geld ausgegeben habe, aber ansonsten,
ich gebe eigentlich
für kaum was Geld aus und ich glaube,
das ist bei ihm ähnlich. Deswegen ist das für ihn auch so
unglaublich viel Geld, dass er dann sagt,
ey, ich weiß gar nicht, wohin damit.
Wenn du es gewohnt bist,
nicht alles,
was du hast, direkt wieder rauszuschmeißen
und auf einmal
doppelt so viel hast wie davor,
dann weißt du nicht, wohin damit.
Was auch nicht schlecht ist.
Besser so, als einfach sinnlos
das Ganze wieder zum Fenster rausschmeißen.
Da hast du eine Menge, die du beispielsweise
in den ETF stecken kannst oder sowas.
Welches Auto hast du dir geholt?
Ein Fiat 500e.
Bin ich mit sehr wenig Geld ausgekommen.
Muss keine Miete bezahlen, das habe ich gar nicht
mitgekriegt. Muss er nicht?
Jetzt überwältigt es mich auch, überhaupt mal
einen Lohn zu bekommen,
der mal die 1.000 Euro bricht.
Der bricht natürlich weit über die 1.000, aber
dafür habe ich eben lange gelernt, sozusagen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Übrigens, ich muss das an der Stelle jetzt einfach mal
sagen, weil ich in letzter Zeit
so Diskussionen mitbekommen habe,
dass,
ich weiß nicht, wo das war, ich habe letztens
irgendeinen Ausschnitt aus irgendeiner Fernsehsendung gesehen
auf YouTube und,
also wurde in irgendeinem Shorts
empfohlen, da hat jemand gesagt,
dass,
ich kann
es nicht zitieren, ich kann es nur
sinngemäß wiedergeben,
dass er super privilegiert ist,
weil er
studiert hat
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Der hat
irgendwie gesagt, er
spielt das
Leben im Easy Mode, weil er studiert hat
und sowas in der Richtung.
Und bei der Aussage
habe ich mir so gedacht, so, naja,
aber du musstest da zuerst mal
studieren, oder?
Ich meine, du musstest erst mal das lernen,
du musstest das durchziehen, du musstest
das schaffen,
du musst auch was können, also es ist ja nicht
so, als könntest du jetzt einfach sagen,
ach ja, ich würde
gerne mein Leben im Easy Mode spielen,
deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal studieren
und dann Easy Mode.
Also dazu muss man sich auch schon ein bisschen reinhängen.
Und je nach Studiengang ist
das sicherlich nicht einfach, erfordert
sehr viel Zeitinvestition,
sehr viel eigener, persönlicher
Einsatz, Durchhaltevermögen,
ja, einen gewissen,
wie kann man es nennen,
Hartnäckigkeit
auch, da kann man doch
im Endeffekt auch sagen, hey, nice,
da habe ich was auf die Reihe
gekriegt, warum ist das Leben im Easy Mode?
Verstehe ich nicht. Und
der hat voll und ganz recht,
hier an der Stelle, der musste sich
da komplett durchbeißen, der hat
einen Hauptschulabschluss gemacht,
der hatte nicht irgendwie
von seinen Eltern super
krass Geld,
der musste sicherlich nebenbei auch noch ein bisschen
gucken, dass er über die Runden kommt,
ja,
dann hat er wahrscheinlich sein Abi
nachgeholt oder wie auch immer das funktioniert hat,
dann hat er studiert,
dann hat er sein Bachelor gemacht, dann hat er sein Master gemacht,
also das fällt dir
nicht einfach in den Schoß, da sagst du nicht einfach so,
ich mach jetzt mal Easy Mode, Bam, Master.
Also, das
Gebäsche, mein Opa war da auch so,
mein Opa konnte,
konnte studierte Leute
nicht ab, aber mein Opa
kam auch noch aus einer anderen Zeit,
und mein Opa
konnte besonders Ärzte
nicht ab, da hat er immer erzählt,
die Halbgötter in weiß sind wieder da,
also, Ärzte
und gerade studierte Leute mochte mein Opa
nicht. Ihr müsst wissen,
mein Opa war,
ich hab übrigens mal ein Video mit meinem Opa aufgenommen,
ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
leider lebt mein Opa nicht mehr,
der war, ähm,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
was der überhaupt gelernt hat,
der war nicht Elektriker, er war,
wie,
wie nennt man denn so jemand,
der in einer
Fabrik
arbeitet und sich um
Maschinenelektronik
und sowas
kümmert, nicht Elektroniker,
vielleicht, vielleicht so eine
Vorstufe von Mechatroniker,
ich weiß, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich weiß es,
ich weiß es gar nicht,
was mein Opa genau gelernt hat,
zumindest, der war hier, war hier in einer Fabrik
und hat sich da um, um Rede gekümmert
und heute würde man wahrscheinlich
sagen, hat die Geräte programmiert, aber damals
wurde nix, Feinmechaniker,
das könnte tatsächlich sein,
dass mein Opa Feinmechaniker war.
Jetzt, wenn ich das
Wort so höre,
das könnte tatsächlich sein,
dass der Feinmechaniker war,
Industriemechaniker, Industrie,
Feinmechaniker, das könnte wirklich
sein, jetzt, wo ich das Wort so lese, zumindest,
ist auch vollkommen egal, hat mit
der Sache, die ich erzählen will, gar nichts zu tun,
ich mein, wo gemeint, mein Opa,
ja, mein Opa war als junger,
äh, weiß ja gar nicht, ob er,
ob er schon volljährig war,
aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich war der irgendwie so
19, 20, der war im Zweiten Weltkrieg, also mein
Opa ist jetzt auch ein paar Jahre jetzt gestorben,
also, der hat richtig ganze
Kacke mitgekriegt, ja, ähm,
der war dann auch, äh,
Kriegsgefangener bei, äh,
den, bei den Amis, hat er immer
erzählt, die Amis konnte er überhaupt nicht ab,
wobei, im Endeffekt, im Nachhinein
betrachtet, war es wahrscheinlich besser, dass er bei den Amis
gelandet ist, anstatt bei den Russen,
und danach, hat er
ja dann hier in einer, in einer Fabrik gearbeitet, ich glaub,
der war Feinmechaniker, das kann schon, das kann schon sein,
zumindest,
der war halt sehr, sagen wir mal so,
arbeitermäßig unterwegs,
und, äh,
auch SPD-Wähler, so der ersten Stunde
dann, und hat auch immer was erzählt von, äh,
ja, die Arbeiter
tragen das alles, und, ach, keine Ahnung,
zumindest,
der war,
jahrzehntelang,
quasi, im Betriebsrat,
damals, das waren so die Anfänge von
Betriebsrat, und, der hat dann auch,
ähm, immer,
immer reden geübt, für seine
Betriebsratssitzung, und sowas,
also, der war da voll engagiert,
weil, weil, weiß ich, das, das war
ich euch sagen, der war so arbeitermäßig, so
voll engagiert, mein Opa, und,
dementsprechend konnte der halt studierte
Leute nicht ab,
weil, aus Prinzip, der konnte Amis
nicht leiden, und studierte Leute nicht
leiden, na, wie das mit studierten Amis aussieht, weiß ich
nicht, da wahrscheinlich doppelt,
und der konnte nicht ab, und gerade Ärzte
konnte er nicht ab, weil, weiß ich, der war, der war so
voll arbeitermäßig, alles, was studiert ist,
ist so, ist so, privilegierter
Elite-Shit, so nach dem Motto, ja,
der hat teilweise schon ein bisschen in die Zeit
der Leute wieder gepasst, mit den Ansichten.
Ich seh das ja ein bisschen anders,
und das hat,
da hatte ich auch regelmäßig
Diskussionen mit meinem Opa, ja,
ähm, der hat das,
seine Antwort war da, ich hab ihm dann auch,
wir hatten ja öfter solche Sachen, ne, so nach dem Motto,
ja, ähm, aber es ist doch auch so, dass sie
das, dass du dazu auch was leisten musst,
ja, du musst das erstmal lernen,
du musst das schaffen, du musst das verstehen, du musst das machen,
du bist dann teilweise mehrere Jahre
am Start, und lernst das,
hat er, hat er alles, hat er alles nicht gelesen,
ja, seine Antwort war immer,
wenn meinem Opa nix mehr eingefallen ist,
da wisst ihr, was der gesagt hat,
ultimatives Argument von meinem Opa
war, du hast recht, und ich hab
meine Ruhe.
Immer, und ich sag, ja, aber Opa,
das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, guck mal, so und so
und so, und wenn du dann gemerkt hast,
dass ihm nix mehr eingefallen ist, hat er dann
gesagt, du hast recht, und ich hab meine Ruhe.
Und da hat er auch keinen
Bock mehr, er sagt, ich will da nix mehr hören von,
du hast recht, ich hab, ja, ja, ja, du hast recht,
du hast recht.
Und, und umgedreht, umgedreht,
umgedreht lief das anders,
umgedreht lief das anders, wenn ich, wenn ich
dann gesagt hab, irgendwann mal, zu irgendwas
so nach dem ODA, muss ich sagen, Opa, weißt du was,
klingt
eigentlich gar nicht so blöd,
ne, klingt eigentlich logisch,
ja, du, und wenn ich dann gesagt hab, du hast recht,
und dann hat er dann, hat er dann immer gesagt,
danach, danach hat er dann immer gesagt,
der Opa hat für gewöhnlich recht.
Da ist ihm natürlich immer, das hat er dann
natürlich gefallen, ne, wenn ich ihm gesagt hab,
dass er recht hat, der Opa hat für gewöhnlich
recht, hat er dann gesagt.
Wie war nochmal der Spruch
mit der Kordel, ja, ähm,
hat,
er hat gesagt, ähm,
später wirst du nochmal schwer Kordel nachgeben
müssen. Der Spruch in dem Kontext
macht jetzt übrigens auch Sinn, ja, aus der Sicht
von meinem Opa, so als richtiger,
ja, so Arbeits,
ähm, wie hat man das, nicht Arbeitsrechtler,
so, so Pro-Pro-Arbeiter-Typ,
ist natürlich klar, ne, was der Chef
sagt, ist Gesetz, und
irgendwie, da muss man später
noch schwer Kordel nachgeben.
Wie bin ich jetzt da überhaupt drauf
gekommen? Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie,
irgendwie hat mich das...
...überhaupt mal einen,
einen Lohn zu bekommen, der mal
die 1.000 Euro bricht, und der bricht natürlich weit
über die 1.000, aber... Bin ich da drauf gekommen?
...dafür hab ich eben lang gelernt, sozusagen.
Ach ja, genau, dass dem halt
auch nicht alles in Schoß,
in Schoß gefallen ist.
Und ich finde, da kann man durchaus
stolz drauf sein, wenn man das hingekriegt hat.
Man muss sich,
man muss sich wirklich für eigene Erfolge
nicht schämen. Hab ich den Eindruck,
dass das, weiß nicht,
so ein bisschen im Trend liegt, aktuell.
Wenn man was auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, darf man
da ruhig auch stolz drauf sein. Gerade wenn
es was ist, wo man sich lange durchgebissen hat,
sechs, sieben Jahre teilweise
am Ball bleiben musste, auch nicht
jeder schafft,
ich kann mir da stolz drauf sein, ja.
Ja, studiert.
Das ist jetzt die
Bude, die mir jetzt
gegeben wurde.
Als Training zieht man ja häufiger um.
Ach, der bekommt von der Firma
die Wohnung gestellt.
Das ist nice.
Auf der anderen Seite
musst du dann halt da hinziehen,
im Endeffekt. Aber, sagen wir mal so,
wenn man damit fein ist,
ist das nice.
Wenn man irgendjemanden suchen muss, der ein, zwei, vier Monate
lässt, gibt die Firma uns eine Wohnung.
Dann bezahlen sie auch die Wohnung.
Und dann bleibt eben mehr hinten übrig.
Ich hab mal das BAföG zurückgezahlt.
6.000 Euro muss ich da zurückbezahlen.
Das ist eine Menge Geld, wenn man noch nie Geld verdient hat.
Hat schon weh getan, als der Brief ankam.
Aber jetzt, wo es weg ist,
fühlt sich schon nice an.
Ja.
Ab jetzt geht es nur noch nach oben.
Also, das sind Anokasien. Nachdem ich aufstehe,
sitze ich auch dann eben immer hier, sozusagen.
Alter, der verstrüht so eine ultra
positive Energie, Mann. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich das aushalten soll.
Ich schau mir die Blätter an, ich schau mir die anderen
Teile an und, ja, hier,
da gucke ich, da mache ich dann
irgendwelche komischen Experimente, um zu gucken,
okay, wachsen die auch im Glas drin und sowas.
In meiner Freizeit gehe ich gerne
ins Fitnessstudio, da ist das schon mit aller Zufriedenheit.
Ja, es sieht auch ziemlich gut,
sagen wir mal,
ordentlich gepumpt aus,
ja.
Mir gefällt das hier,
viel Gewicht zu bewegen,
diese Power sozusagen zu haben.
Ich hätte ja,
wenn ich um 18 Uhr fertig bin mit der Arbeit,
überhaupt keine Energie mehr,
ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Ich mache meine eineinhalb
Stunde Runde
hier im Freien und dann ist
aber auch gut. Nochmal extra
irgendwo hin, dann da trainieren
und dann wieder zurück.
Ey, da hätte ich keinen Bock.
Der ist ja vor halb neun nicht daheim.
Und dann muss er noch was essen.
Der macht sich dann was zu essen, dann fällt er 22
Uhr ins Bett und morgen geht es weiter.
Max, gehst du jeden Tag nach der Arbeit laufen
oder wie machst du das? Also, ich
mache das folgendermaßen.
Ich gehe jeden zweiten bis dritten Tag,
je nachdem wie die Woche sich das anbietet,
auch mit Gemiete und sonst was und
Abstände und so. Ich gehe
jeden zweiten bis dritten Tag
vormittags rennen. Das mache
ich meistens gleich morgen früh.
Ich stehe auf, gehe an den Rechner,
logge mich ein, gucke ein bisschen
rum und dann ist meistens noch nichts
los. Da gucke ich mal ins Monitoring rein,
ob alles gut ist. Dann schreibe ich im Chat.
Ich bin nochmal kurz weg und gehe schnell
so zwischen,
sagen wir mal so um die 40,
30 bis 40
Minuten
rennen.
Da ist noch
nichts los auf der Arbeit
und das ist auch nicht so wild,
weil ich kriege eh Mittagspause
abgezogen und ich futter meistens vorm Rechner.
Selten sitze ich auch mal unten.
Ja, und...
dann mache ich den restlichen Tag
home. Also das ist an den Tagen, wo ich daheim bin.
Ja, wenn ich nach Frankfurt
bin, sieht es natürlich anders aus.
Aber glücklicherweise kann ich
die meiste Zeit Homeoffice machen.
Ich habe das Handy von der Arbeit dabei,
wenn ich eine Runde rennen gehe.
Also wenn es irgendwie wichtig ist, kann ich mich anrufen.
Trägst du das als Pause ein? Manchmal.
Ich träge das immer dann als Pause ein, wenn es
länger dauert. Letztens
musste ich zum Beispiel einen Umweg
zurücklaufen, weil ein freilaufender Hund
am Main...
Das hat dann, glaube ich, 45 Minuten oder 50
Minuten oder so, genau das habe ich eingetragen.
Aber ansonsten geht sich das meistens relativ
gut mit automatischen Sachen, die man abgezogen
kommt, aus. Und
man darf auch nicht vergessen, ich mache auch öfters
abends was, ohne es aufzuschreiben.
Also ich habe mich auch schon öfters
abends eingeloggt, weil ich im Teams gesehen habe,
dass irgendein Entwickler was geschrieben hat.
Und wir haben noch mal kurz eine Viertelstunde geguckt
und sowas.
Ehrlich gesagt,
und das sage ich jetzt nicht, um zum
guten Wetter zu machen, falls mein Chef zuguckt,
weil er kennt den Stream nicht, aber trotzdem,
ich glaube sogar unterm Strich
mache ich durch das ganze
Draufgegucke, ich habe ja sogar das Handy auf
dem Klo und gucke da teilweise die Mails durch,
ich gucke abends noch mal rein, gucke mal kurz noch,
okay, ah, da haben noch Leute in Teams geschrieben,
irgendwie 21 Uhr, wenn ich das Handy noch mal in der
Hand habe. Das alles zusammen,
ja, oder noch mal schnell einloggen,
weil ich gesehen habe, irgendein Entwickler hat mich angeschrieben,
das alles zusammen
ist eher
eine positive Bilanz für die Firma
als für mich
von den Stunden her.
Deswegen, ich schreibe das nur auf,
wenn das wirklich bedeutend länger dauert
als die normale Runde.
Und das mache ich vormittags, so jeden
zweiten bis dritten Tag.
Ich time das immer so, dass ich sonntags die lange Runde,
morgens, morgen früh, die lange Runde rennen kann.
Da brauche ich mindestens eine Tagpause
vorher, dass das funktioniert.
Und dann, wenn ich fertig bin,
so 15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr,
gehe ich meistens noch eineinhalb Stunden ganz
normal raus und laufe hier eine Runde
oder fahre ein bisschen hier ins,
ich nenne es mal, Gebirge, wobei
sich da, wie gesagt, die Schweizer und Österreicher drüber kaputt
lachen. Ich habe euch ja mal meine,
eine meiner Lieblingsrunden gezeigt, hier so
durch die Berge, das laufe ich dann meistens
noch, aber ich renne da nicht, ja.
Also morgens wird da wirklich gerannt. Ich laufe da einfach
ganz normal eineinhalb Stunden
bisschen noch durch die frische Luft, so ein bisschen
über die paar Hügel drüber
und dann wieder zurück.
Und dann sitze ich wieder vorm PC
und mache Streamvideo
oder cry in the MMOs bis
23, 22,
22.30 Uhr oder so.
Und
in den Tagen, wo ich nicht laufe,
setze ich mich auf meinen
Fahrradsmart-Trainer hier daheim.
Weil ich habe leider aktuell kein
Fahrrad, es ist sehr zu kalt zum Fahren.
Nein. Ich gehe morgen.
Morgens. Morgens.
Achso.
Ähm, abends. Ja, abends ist,
tatsächlich nur ganz normales Laufen.
Ich jogge
nichts abends, nur morgens.
Abends ist ganz normal
recht zügiges, aber entspanntes Laufen.
Nicht Joggen.
Hast du Bereitschaft? Ja.
Aber heute nicht.
Hast du Stehtisch? Habe ich, aber
Laufbahn habe ich nicht. Stehtisch habe ich.
So, und
an den Tagen, wo ich nicht renne,
mache ich
meistens, wobei, wo gemerkt,
ich lasse auch manchmal Tage wirklich, wirklich
frei, setze ich mich hier auf meinen Smart,
Smart-Fahrrad-Trainer.
Und wenn ich ganz heftig drauf bin,
mache ich manchmal sogar vormittags rennen,
dann, ähm, die Spaziergehrunde,
und dann abends nochmal
45 Minuten fahren. Aber das mache ich selten. Das ist nur, wenn ich
gar so viel Energie irgendwie übrig habe.
Und auch gerade kein Kreisel-Cry
im Stream oder sonst was anderes ansteht.
Ja, ich time das meistens so,
dass ich rennen,
Fahrrad fahren, renne, oder rennen,
Fahrrad fahren, Pause, oder
rennen, Pause, fahren. Irgendwie so.
Dass das, dass das passt. Also, ich renne mehr, als
dass ich Fahrrad fahre. Ja.
Aber eins habe ich gemerkt, seitdem ich regelmäßig
auf meinem Smart-Trainer hier Fahrrad fahre,
ich merke es deutlich später beim
Treppenlaufen in den Oberschenkeln.
Also, ich bin jetzt ja schon
öfters mal bei uns auf der Arbeit in 8.
Stock?
Ne, ne, ist Blödsinn. In 28.
Stock gelaufen, aber nicht von unten,
sondern vom 25. Stock.
So rum. Das ist Blödsinn. In 28.
Stock, vom 25. Stock gelaufen.
Und, äh,
wenn du das zackig
läufst, merkst du es, habe ich es am Anfang
immer noch gemerkt, gut in den Oberschenkeln.
Aber seitdem ich
regelmäßig Fahrrad fahre, muss ich sagen,
ich merke eigentlich nur, dass es mir warm wird.
Ich merke nicht mehr dieses
Brennen in den Oberschenkeln wegen Belastung.
Ja. Also,
ein bisschen was, ein bisschen was bringt es anscheinend
doch, regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren.
Fährst du auf Swift? Ja, mache ich.
Ich habe, ich habe ein, ein, ein Swift-Abo.
Tatsächlich. Ich heiße
dort, falls ihr mal jemanden seht,
Omega-Keckel.
Kein Witz, das ist mein, mein Swift-Name.
Den musst du Vor- und Nachname
eingeben. Ich heiße Omega-
Keckel.
Mir ist nichts anderes eingefallen.
Falls ihr mal ein Omega-
Keckel seht, bei euch auf Swift,
da bin ich das.
Welchen Home-Trainer hast du? Ich habe ein
Wahoo
Kicker Core.
Da macht man das,
das hintere Rad aus dem, aus
dem...
Das hintere Rad kommt, kommt raus
vom Fahrrad und dann wird
quasi die Kette auf diesen Trainer
hier drauf gelegt.
Die Kassette ist nicht dabei.
Da habe ich mir noch eine,
noch eine
passende Kassette gekauft hier, also mit den
Zahnrädern.
Also, wenn ihr den Omega-Keckel seht,
wie war das, durch Joggen brennen die Beine nicht,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
das, durch Fahrradfahren
brennen die Beine nicht mehr beim
Treppenlaufen, das wollte ich sagen.
Ich bin jetzt öfters auf der Arbeit schon vom
25. Stock in den 28. hochgelaufen
und am Anfang habe ich es immer gemerkt in den Beinen,
aber seitdem ich regelmäßig Fahrrad fahre,
mittlerweile brennt es nicht mehr beim Hochlaufen
die Treppe in den Beinen, sondern mir wird es
einfach nur warm.
Das Joggen hat erstaunlich
wenig Auswirkungen
auf meine Fahrrad-Performance, muss ich
sagen. Gut, ich weiß es nicht, ich habe
deutlich länger angefangen zu Joggen als
zu Fahrradfahren.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
dass es sind echt zwei
unabhängige Sportarten.
Also sicherlich
hat man die eine Ausdauer vom einen bis hin
beim anderen, aber
die Regionen, die beim
Fahrradfahren beansprucht sind,
sind schon andere.
Beim Fahrradfahren merke ich es
richtig krass in den oberen Schenkeln,
beim Joggen ist es eigentlich eher
kreislaufmäßig, wo ich
nicht mehr kann.
Also ich habe es jetzt bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft, dass ich kreislaufmäßig beim
Fahrradfahren nicht mehr konnte, es waren
eher die Beine, die mir zu sehr weh getan haben.
Wobei ich es einmal, einmal habe ich es echt
übertrieben, da habe ich es mal versucht
so zu machen, wie es die ganzen
Pros machen und zwar
möglichst schnell fahren,
also nein, möglichst viele Umdrehungen,
also viele RPMs
zu haben und halt
nicht so, nicht so,
wie nennt man das denn,
also nicht so einen hohen Gang,
also nicht so einen schweren Gang zu fahren,
und leichter
und dafür irgendwie 100
RPM zu treten, Kadenz, genau,
Kadenz.
Kannst ja quasi eher so Drehmoment-mäßig
mit kleinem Gang oder halt schnell,
schnell paddeln und ich habe mal so
bei Swift so eine, die haben so eine,
so eine, weiß nicht, ob das Weekly ist,
ich glaube das ist Weekly, weil da habe ich
jetzt schon ein paar gemacht von,
Weekly, so Weekly Climb Challenge,
da suchen die sich immer das Profil
von irgendeinem halbwegs bekannten
Berganstieg raus und bilden dann,
das in Swift ab, dann kannst du hochfahren.
Da bin ich ja mal
einen hochgefahren, ich glaube irgendwie 9,5 Kilometer
oder so, war schon, hat sich echt,
hat sich echt ne ganze Weile gezogen, war jetzt nicht so
super steil und da habe ich das mal
probiert, Leute, ich bin da oben
angekommen und da dachte ich mir,
ich bin im Arsch, aber
komplett im Arsch und dann habe ich den Fehler
gemacht, ich bin volle Pulle gefahren
bis über die Ziellinie und dann
habe ich den Fehler gemacht, ich, ich
konnte nicht mehr, weil mir die Beine weh getan haben
und dann bin ich vom Fahrrad runtergesprungen,
also nicht runtergesprungen, sondern halt direkt von den Pedalen
runter, sodass ich das Fahrrad zwischen den Beinen hatte
und mir
schwindelig geworden.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum die sich immer,
warum die sich immer ausfahren danach.
Ich habe noch nie so krass
meinen Herzschlag gespürt und, und
benommen
gewesen von Sport machen.
Ich bin, ich bin da hochgestrampelt,
zack, zack, zack, zack, zack,
über die Ziellinie und vom Fahrrad runtergesprungen
und ich stand da und ich musste mich echt,
festhalten weiter am Lenker,
obwohl ich gestanden habe, weil es mir
komisch geworden ist. Also,
deswegen verstehe ich, dass die alle
nicht vom Fahrrad springen, sondern
immer noch 1, 2, 3
Minuten langsam weiterfahren,
bis die wieder ein bisschen runter
gekommen sind. Macht schon
Sinn, ja? Wusste ich
bis dahin auch nicht.
Ich habe gedacht, meine Brust
explodiert da, ich habe richtig krass den Herzschlag
gespürt. Naja, zumindest
so sieht es, so sieht es aktuell aus. Ich wollte
bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal gucken,
ich glaube, das, wir gucken das mal schnell
fertig, weil das ist eigentlich jetzt ja
durch, außer dass er ein bisschen pumpt.
Man verdient hier
viel Geld, man kriegt aber auch
sehr viel Verantwortung.
Übrigens, bei dem siehst du, dass der schlau ist.
Ich vergleiche
das mal mit den Mädels aus
meinem Arbeitsamtkurs,
denen ihr erklärtes
Lebensziel, Lebensziel war,
bei einigen, ich habe ja mal ein Video drüber gemacht,
von so vielen Kerlen wie möglich
Kinder zu bekommen, damit sie quasi
leben können
vom Kinder bekommen.
Und der
ist komplett das Gegenteil von
den Leuten aus dem Arbeitsamtkurs.
Der ist schlau,
der ist motiviert,
der weiß, was er macht.
Ich habe da mal ein Video drüber gemacht,
ja,
das hier, ich habe da mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
Ich musste mal einen Kurs beim
Arbeitsamt machen
und da hatte ich echt komplette,
wie nennt man das so,
ja,
das war für mich komplett
andere Welt,
die Leute, die ich da getroffen habe.
Und da gab es ein paar Mädels,
also
man muss dazu sagen, alle dort,
ich war da nicht alt, ich war da,
weiß ich nicht, 20 oder so, ich war wirklich
nicht alt. Und die ganzen Mädels
dort, bis auf eine, die
hatten schon alle Kinder,
oder waren gerade schwanger.
Und ich habe von einigen
dort den Plan gehört,
das erzähle ich, das erzähle ich
im Video noch ein bisschen ausführlicher,
von einigen dort habe ich den Plan gehört,
ihr,
so war stehen geblieben,
also ihre Lebensplanung ist, von möglichst
vielen Kerlen Kinder zu bekommen, dass sie dann
davon leben können.
Die eine hat mir sogar erzählt, dass
sie neben ihrem Hauptmann noch einen zweiten
Stecher hat. Das war, Zitat,
das hat die so gesagt zu mir. Ich weiß nicht,
beim besten Willen nicht, warum die mir das
so erzählt hat. Vielleicht sollte ich der dritte
Stecher werden, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber
die hat sich gedacht,
auf geht's.
Hast du nicht angeboten? Nein, hab ich nicht.
Aber ich war nett zu
der, vielleicht hat sie das reininterpretiert.
Ich habe der geholfen,
einen Brief zu formulieren
ans Arbeitsamt. Leute,
ich habe das nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass es tatsächlich Leute gibt,
die
ich will jetzt nicht sagen, nicht lesen
und schreiben können,
aber so
schlecht und unverständlich lesen und
schreiben können, dass du es nicht verstehst.
Die hat sich,
die hat sich die ganze Zeit aufgeregt darüber,
dass die ihr vom Amt immer nicht
antworten, wie sie, was sie fragt
und dass sie sie nicht verstehen und so.
Und
da habe ich halt, habe ich zu ihr gesagt, er zeigt
doch mal, was du denen geschrieben hast. Und Leute,
ohne Scheiß,
äh, du konntest das nicht
verstehen. Das war kein Deutsch.
Also es war Deutsch, aber es war,
es waren keine Wörter aneinander
gereiht, die einen Sinn ergeben
haben. Das war ganz weird. Also ich
kann es jetzt nicht mehr wiedergeben. Es hat absolut
keinen Sinn ergeben, was sie da geschrieben hat.
Ja, die hat dann erklärt, was sie wollte,
aber das, was da geschrieben
ist, hat wirklich null, gar
keinen Sinn ergeben. War sie
Deutsche?
Ja.
Ich glaube schon. Wir hatten
viele, weiß ich, ob man nicht Deutsche
sagen darf, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also
Leute mit Migrationshintergrund
waren bestimmt
60, 70 Prozent,
ähm, wo zumindest auf jeden Fall die Eltern
Migrationshintergrund
hatten. Aber das war, glaube ich, eine Deutsche.
Ja, zumindest äußerst deutsch aus.
Zumindest, die konnte, die konnte kein Wort
richtig da schreiben und zusammen,
ja, also
zusammenhängende Sätze, die man verstanden hat,
auch nicht. Und da habe ich halt
mir den Brief durchgelesen und hab gesagt, hier, ich
weiß, warum die dir nichts antworten,
die verstehen das nicht, die verstehen das nicht.
Ähm, da habe ich
es halt gefragt, ob ich,
ob wir irgendwie mal drei, vier Sätze schreiben wollen.
Die sagt mir was, was er will und dann schreibe ich, schreibe ich
das halt so auf, dass man es versteht.
Und vielleicht hat sie das schon so gedeutet, wie ich will
der dritte Stecher werden, keine Ahnung. Zumindest
die Erklärung, warum das
so schlecht ist, hat mich ja noch mehr schockiert.
Was meint ihr, was
sie gesagt hat darauf?
So, wenn es ja noch umging, warum
das, warum das so schlecht geschrieben ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein,
das wäre ja noch eine schlüssige
Erklärung gewesen. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Die Erklärung war,
richtig, die Erklärung
war, sie muss nicht
schreiben, ihr Freund kann das.
Das war die Erklärung da drauf, ja.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt
hat sie gesagt, sie selbst kann
gar nicht schreiben oder noch schlechter
schreiben und deswegen hat ihr Freund
das geschrieben, also der erste Stecher in dem
Fall. Oder der
zweite, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher. Aber ich glaube,
der erste. Und der war auch
komplett unfähig.
Leute, ich hatte echt ganz große Schwierigkeiten
in diesem Kurs, weil ich es nicht für
möglich gehalten habe, dass solche Leute wirklich
existieren in dieser Masse.
Naja, der ist halt das komplette
Gegenteil davon. Dementsprechend
wird er auch nie ein Arbeitsamtkurs machen müssen.
Der ist
easy in ein paar Jahren, super krasser
Business-Strengths-Manager bei
Südzucker oder bei irgendeinem anderen Land.
Wisst ihr, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
dass das so ein typischer, ich kann sie,
dass so ein typischer Startup-Typ irgendwie
so von 24-7
ultra motiviert,
super, super gut drauf,
hat immer Energie.
Das ist so ein typischer Startup-Mensch.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Auch vom Alter her.
Wie viel kommt denn jetzt am Ende raus?
Vielen Dank, das war's.
Wie viel Überschuss, was?
Siehste, der kommt, wie ich gesagt
habe, ich glaube, Lebensstilmäßig sind wir
tatsächlich relativ ähnlich,
der kommt einfach mit wenig aus.
Ja, ja,
das ist das, was er wirklich überwiesen hat,
also das, was er wirklich übrig hat, ausgeben kann.
Ohne Miete, ja, natürlich.
Aber, ist doch egal,
es ging mir nur um den Anteil von
was der ausgibt. Guck mal,
75 Euro Freizeit-
Lifestyle, das ist nix.
Da geb ich mehr aus.
Und ich geb schon nicht viel aus.
Wobei, geb ich wirklich,
was geb ich für Freizeit und Lifestyle aus?
Ähm,
sinnloses Elektronikzeug bei
AliExpress manchmal kaufen ist ja nicht Lifestyle.
Wobei, ist das Lifestyle?
Ähm, das Rose-Fahrrad.
Richtig, richtig, ja, das ist richtig.
Ich hab einmalig Geld ausgegeben für
ein Fahrrad, korrekt. Und jetzt ist es kaputt.
Nice. Ich wollte doch gerade
mal gucken, wenn wir gerade dabei sind,
ob es mal wieder ein
Fahrrad in meiner Größe gibt.
Danach muss ich übrigens was essen.
International ist auch okay.
Äh,
Moment mal, so viel angezeigt.
What the fuck?
Ich glaub, das da. Swift ist Lifestyle.
Stimmt, da bezahl ich 14 Euro oder so im Monat
für, ähm, oder 7?
Nee. Nee.
Ich bring's
gerade durcheinander. Entweder kostet
YouTube in Deutschland 14 Euro und Swift
7 oder umgedreht. Oder beides
14? Ja, beides 14.
Glücklicherweise hab ich nicht YouTube in
Deutschland gekauft.
Wo ist das denn jetzt?
Alter, könnt ihr mal bitte die Modelle zeigen?
Genau.
Double Speed.
Hä? Ah, hier.
Also das ist das, was ich aktuell
habe, was aber kaputt ist.
Und
eigentlich würde ich gerne genau das gleiche
wieder kaufen, allerdings am liebsten mit
1x12 elektronisch, was es noch nicht gibt.
Sold out.
In blau.
Sold out. Nice.
Kann man vergessen.
Obwohl es sogar ein bisschen reduziert ist aktuell.
Ich hab das hier noch bezahlt für...
Ich glaub 3300 hab ich bezahlt.
Gibt's nicht. Tja.
Sehr geil. Aber nicer Dude hier.
Der wird's
Business Enterprise
mäßig noch weit bringen. Da macht
Karrierecriner, hat Karrierecriner
Qualitäten.
Kann ich nicht, weil der Rose Shop bei mir
in Globetrotter zugemacht hat.
Es gibt zwei Rose Stores,
gab es bei mir. Frankfurter, Globetrotter,
ich glaube in Wiesbaden. Beide haben zugemacht.
Wie viele Tabs? Moment, Moment.
Ich kann in meiner VM noch ein paar aufmachen.
Und hier, hier
und in Kron, also schon ordentlich viele
Tabs braucht man da.
Irgendwie, ich sag's doch immer wieder, irgendwie muss man
wenigstens... Leute!
Pock!
Endlich haben wir die Hälfte des
RAMs wenigstens voll.
Sind sie immer noch
24 Gig frei, aber immerhin ist
die Hälfte des RAMs voll.
Ohne Scheiß!
Ja, genau so ist es.
Da passt noch mehr rein.
Ja.
Remdisk, ja. Genau, dann krieg
ich's auch voll.
Okay Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Relativ langer Stream heute und wenig Videos,
viel geschwätzt. Aber letztens hat doch
jemand geschrieben, Max, Laberstreams sind
mir am liebsten. Also denn.
Es gibt übrigens gleich ein neues Video.
Wenn ich, wenn ich gegessen hab.
Warte.
Umut, auch mal wieder am Start.
Nice.
Lange nicht gehört.
Noch eine Frage. Pass auf,
jetzt kommt was total wirres.
Ich kenn ihn, der hat schon öfters
wirre Sachen gefragt. Pass auf, jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt was total wirres gleich. Wo ist
der Chainlore eigentlich? Der Chainlore ist
der King auf wirre Sachen im Chat.
Was hältst du von Wifi Man
von Uni... Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Wifi Man ist das nicht von...
Nee, Moment. Mikrotik
heißt, das heißt anders.
Ähm.
Die haben nämlich auch so eine Wifi
Management Software, die, die Crap ist.
Weiß ich nicht. Hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Keine Ahnung. Der Dongle.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin von Unified Zeug ja, weißt
ja, komplett weg. Keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich schalt das Video, ich schalt
das Video 14 Uhr dann frei.
Okay? Müsst ihr aber auch alle
gucken 14 Uhr, okay?
Chatge.
Ich achte drauf, wer guckt.
Wir machen's jetzt so. Ich geh jetzt
auf und schalte das Video frei.
Okay? Und dann müsst
ihr zum Erkennen unter dem Video
Was machen wir denn?
Keck Wait, okay?
Ihr müsst unter dem Video, also alle, die jetzt
vom Stream gleich kommen und sich das Video angucken,
müssen
Keck Wait schreiben in den Kommentaren
unter dem Video. Dann weiß ich, dass ihr vom Stream kommt.
Quality is destiny.
Nein, flüssig.
Ihr könnt auch Keck Leave schreiben.
Okay? So.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns. Ein paar Minuten ist das Video da.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
See you. Keck Eat.
Keck Eat könnt ihr auch schreiben, ist auch okay.
Gibt's morgen einen Stream? Weiß noch nicht.
Ich muss mal wieder ein bisschen Kreisel-Crime streamen.
Was?
Ja, aber gucken
kannst du's immer noch. Okay. Bis dann,
Leute. Macht's gut. See you.